This is the Earth at a time when the dinosaurs roamed a lush, fertile planet. A piece of rock, just six miles wide, changed all that. It hit with a force of 10,000 nuclear weapons. A trillion tons of dirt and rock hurtled into the atmosphere. Creating a suffocating blanket of dust, the sun was powerless to penetrate for a thousand. years. It happened before. Then again.
这是恐龙在一个繁茂、肥沃的星球上漫步时期的地球。一块仅仅六英里宽的岩石改变这一切。它撞击的威力相当于1万枚核武器。一万亿吨的泥土和岩石冲向大气层。这形成了一层令人窒息的尘埃毯，太阳千年无法穿透。这以前发生过。然后又发生了。
It's just a question of when. Everyone, buckle in for Armageddon. I'm Jenna Fisher, and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together, and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week, we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind-the-scenes details.
这只是个时间问题。各位，系好安全带迎接世界末日吧。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作终极办公室恋人播客。每周，我们将通过独家幕后访谈更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。
and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. We have a big, big episode today. We really do. Welcome to our breakdown of the 1998 summer blockbuster Armageddon. Bungung, gung. Explosions! So many explosions.
以及许多闺蜜的故事。我们是办公室辣妹6.0。我们今天有一集非常非常重磅的节目。真的有。欢迎收看我们对1998年暑期大片《绝世天劫》的深度解析。嘭嘭，嘭。爆炸！好多的爆炸。
We said we might do this a while back and we got mail. Amber W from Brighton, Michigan, wrote us to say, You mentioned doing a watch of Armageddon, and you guys will podcast the crap out of that. I need it in my life. And Kelly B from Westfield, Indiana, who listens with her family, said, I've been listening to your podcast since the first episode, and it's truly my favorite one I listen to. We desperately want you to break down Armageddon. You mentioned it, and we are all in.
我们不久前说过可能会做这个，然后我们收到了邮件。来自密歇根州布莱顿的安贝·W写信给我们说，你们提到要看《绝世天劫》，而你们这群人会对它进行超级播客解说。我的生活需要这个。印第安纳州韦斯特菲尔德的凯利·B和她的家人一起听节目，她说，我从第一集开始就一直在听你们的播客，这真的是我最喜欢的节目。我们非常希望你们深度解析《绝世天劫》。你们提到了，我们全力支持。
I showed it to my kids recently because you mentioned it, and it is so bad, we totally need you to break it down. please, please. Podcasts the crap out of something might be my new favorite expression, Amber. You guys also know that this movie, Armageddon, does live in the lore of the office. Yeah. We briefly discussed this movie in the very early days of our podcast when we broke down the episode, The Fight. So you guys, if you remember, Michael Scott is wanting Jim to punch him really hard in the stomach. And Jim suggests that he have Dwight do it.
我最近因为你们提到它，把它放给我的孩子们看，它太糟糕了，我们绝对需要你们深度解析。求求你们，求求了。把某事进行超级播客解说可能是我的新口头禅，安贝。大家也知道这部电影《绝世天劫》确实存在于《办公室》的传说中。是的。我们在播客早期解析《打架》那一集时简短讨论过这部电影。所以大家如果还记得的话，迈克尔·斯科特想让吉姆狠狠地朝他肚子打一拳。而吉姆建议他让德怀特来。
And then we learned this tidbit about Michael and Dwight. Go ahead. Do it? Just have Dwight punch you. Oh, yeah. Well, that would be kind of worthless because I know a ton of 14-year-old girls are going to kick his ass. You know a ton of 14-year-old girls? What belt are they?
然后我们了解到了关于迈克尔和德怀特的这个八卦。请讲。干嘛？让德怀特打你一拳不就行了。哦，对。不过那可能有点没用，因为我知道一大群14岁的小女孩都会把他屁股踢烂。你认识一大群14岁的小女孩？她们是什么段位的？
Look, Dwight is a wuss. When we rented Armageddon, he cried at the end of it. Michael, I told you. That was because it was New Year's Eve and it started to snow at exactly midnight. Bruce Willis. I could leave him on the asteroid, boo! Okay, I'll punch you. Oh, okay.
听着，德怀特是个懦夫。我们租《绝世天劫》的时候，他在结尾哭了。迈克尔，我告诉过你。那是因为那是除夕夜，而且刚好在午夜开始下雪。布鲁斯·威利斯。我可以把他留在小行星上，呜！好吧，我打你。哦，好吧。
Here we go. All right, come on. Go! F! Amazing. So Michael and Dwight watched Armageddon on New Year's Eve. And now, lady, we have watched it. We have.
我们开始吧。好吧，来吧。上！F！太棒了。所以迈克尔和德怀特在除夕夜看了《绝世天劫》。而现在，女士们，我们看了。我们确实看了。
There's so much to discuss. But let's dive into the facts and stats. Yeah, I'll kick us off. As you said, Jenna was released in 1998 on July 1st. So kind of like around the July 4th holiday. Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. Here's a little description.
有太多东西要讨论了。但让我们先来看看事实和数据。好的，我来开个头。如你所说，珍娜，它于1998年7月1日上映。所以有点像在7月4日独立日假期前后。哦，是的。嗯嗯。这里有个简短的介绍。
After discovering that an asteroid, the size of Texas will impact Earth in less than a month, NASA recruits a misfit team of deep core drillers to save the planet. Yeah, they do. Want to hear the tagline? I do. It's so good. Ready?
在发现一颗得克萨斯州大小的小行星将在不到一个月内撞击地球后，美国宇航局招募了一支由深层地心钻探工组成的乌合之众团队来拯救地球。是的，他们确实这么做了。想听宣传标语吗？我想听。太棒了。准备好了吗？
Mm-hmm. It's closer than you think. Hmm. I feel like that's what she said. I have another tagline. What? Explosions and yelling. Oh, that's very good.
嗯嗯。它比你想象的要近。嗯。我觉得这话听着耳熟。我还有另一个宣传标语。什么？爆炸和尖叫。哦，那非常好。
Yeah. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Okay. It was rated PG-13, Jenna, I haven't told you. We don't know what each other are both sharing today, guys. It's been very hard not to share my thoughts about this movie with you. I've been sharing them a little bit with Sam because I couldn't help myself.
是啊。是啊。嗯嗯。好的。它是PG-13级的，珍娜，我还没告诉你。我们不知道今天彼此都在分享什么，伙计们。要忍住不跟你们分享我对这部电影的想法真的很难。我跟萨姆分享了一点，因为我实在忍不住。
Yeah, you needed someone to bear witness. We have been living in a vacuum. But Jenna, I want to tell you something right now. I know more about this movie than I feel like I did about any subject I took in college. There is a DVD commentary that has been. lost. You can't find it anymore. It was on a laser disc. I found it online. Amazing. It's two hours and 35 minutes. It's Michael Bay, Bruce Willis, Jerry Bruckheimer, and Ben Affleck. I listened to it. The whole thing? I crapped out at about two hours. Okay, so the last 35 minutes,
是的，你需要一个人来作证。我们一直生活在真空里。但珍娜，我现在要告诉你一件事。关于这部电影，我知道的甚至比我在大学里学的任何一门学科还要多。有一个DVD评论音轨已经失传了。你再也找不到了。它曾在一张激光视盘上。我在网上找到了。太神奇了。它有两小时35分钟。那是迈克尔·贝、布鲁斯·威利斯、杰瑞·布鲁克海默和本·阿弗莱克。我听了。整整听完？我听了大约两个小时就撑不下去了。好吧，所以最后35分钟，
I was like, I get it now. Lady, it is one of the most insane rides of your life. Like, I want you to go on a road trip and listen to it. Anyway, all that to say, I know why they wanted a PG-13 movie. Tell us. Okay. Ask me any kind of random shit as we break this down. Michael Bay said, and I'm quoting him, that his grandfather said to him, if you want to make a lot of money, find something you can sell to Middle America. Okay.
我想，我现在懂了。女士，这是你一生中最疯狂的旅程之一。就像，我想让你去公路旅行时听它。总之，所有这些都是为了说明，我知道他们为什么想要一部PG-13的电影。告诉我们吧。好的。在我们剖析这个的过程中，随便问我什么乱七八糟的事情。迈克尔·贝说——我引用他的话——他的祖父对他说，如果你想赚大笔钱，就找一样你能卖给美国中产阶级的东西。好吧。
He said this movie's patriotic. He wanted it to be PG-13, even though that meant he had to dumb down some of it, so 13-year-olds could get it. it, but then also still make it exciting enough for the adults in the audience. And he thinks he accomplished that. And I think he did too. He did. Yeah. Yeah. Well, this movie is two hours and 31 minutes. Right. The commentary is just a few minutes longer. That's what I was going to ask you. Two hours and 35 minutes. Okay. Yeah. It is real long. Real long. Did you see this in theaters? Do you remember the first time you saw it? I did see it in theaters.
他说这部电影很爱国。他希望它是PG-13级的，尽管这意味着他必须把其中一些内容弱化，以便13岁的孩子能看懂，但同时仍然要让它对成年观众来说足够惊险刺激。他认为他做到了。我也觉得他做到了。他确实做到了。是啊。是啊。好吧，这部电影时长两小时31分钟。对。评论音轨只比它长了几分钟。这就是我要问你的。两小时35分钟。好吧。是的。真的很长。真的很长。你在电影院看这个了吗？你还记得你第一次看它的时候吗？我在电影院看过。
Okay. And I don't have a strong memory of seeing it, and I'm confused by that now because... You're like, how could I not remember? How could I not remember that? I mean, I saw it, and I shared this when we broke down the fight for office ladies, that I saw it with my dad, who is a drilling engineer, a deep sea drilling engineer, like on oil rigs out in the ocean. Like where we meet Bruce Willis and his team.
好吧。我对看它没有深刻的记忆，我现在对此感到困惑，因为……你会想，我怎么会不记得？我怎么会不记得那个？我的意思是，我看过，而且我们在为《办公室辣妹》解析《打架》那一集时分享过，我和我爸爸一起看的，他是一名钻井工程师，深海钻井工程师，就像海洋中的石油钻井平台那样。就像我们遇到布鲁斯·威利斯和他的团队的地方。
Exactly. So I went and saw this movie with my dad, and I'm going to share some of his reactions later. I can't wait. But yeah, so what I don't know is how I made it through the movie without peeing like four times. Yeah, you probably went to the bathroom several times. I had to have.
没错。所以我跟我爸一起去看这部电影，我稍后会分享他的一些反应。我等不及了。但是，是的，所以我不知道我是怎么在没上四次厕所的情况下看完这部电影的。是的，你可能去了好几次洗手间。我肯定去过。
Matt, Sam, do you remember seeing this movie for the first time? Did you see it in theaters? No, I never saw this until a week ago. No, Sam. No, this move, this was all brand new to me. Oh, my gosh. What were your thoughts? I'll let you know as we go.
马特，萨姆，你们还记得第一次看这部电影吗？你们是在电影院看的吗？没有，我直到一周前才看。没有，萨姆。不，这部电影，对我来说全都是崭新的。噢，天哪。你有什么想法？我们边走边聊，我会告诉你的。
Okay, I took detailed notes. Oh my gosh, please let us know. Okay. Matt? I definitely saw it in theaters. The only thing I really remembered from the movie was the Animal Cracker scene. I don't know what that says about me,
好的，我做了详细的笔记。噢，天哪，请一定要告诉我们。好的。马特？我绝对是在电影院看的。我从这部电影中真正记住的唯一东西就是动物饼干的那场戏。我不知道这说明了我什么，
but it's literally the only thing that I could tell you about this movie. I know. I was taking notes. I was like, okay, Animal Crackers. No, God, please tell me you. never have recreated this moment. Please tell me I've been busted out animal crackers on a lady's belly. Guys, doesn't Michael Scott reference animal crackers in something about wooing a woman?
但这真的是关于这部电影我能告诉你的唯一一件事了。我知道。我在做笔记时想，好吧，动物饼干。不，上帝啊，请告诉我你从来没有重现过这个时刻。请告诉我，我没有在女人的肚皮上掏出过动物饼干。伙计们，迈克尔·斯科特是不是在关于追求女性的某个情节里提到过动物饼干？
I swear. Oh my gosh. Someone Google it. Wait, Jenna, what did you find? She's looking very excited. Okay. According to Dundrapedia, in threat level midnight, there is a flash back scene of Michael Scarn and his wife.
我发誓。噢，天哪。谁去谷歌一下。等等，珍娜，你发现了什么？她看起来非常兴奋。好吧。根据《德克兰百科全书》，在《危机午夜》中，有一个迈克尔·斯卡恩和他的妻子的闪回场景。
And one of the sequences is a take on the scene where Ben Affleck puts the animal cracker on Liv Tyler's stomach. So two Armageddon references in the office, folks. This is the brilliance of the office, though. You think something's mentioned and just like, oh, will we ever see that again? And then it is woven back in. Yeah. I love that.
其中一个序列取材于本·阿弗莱克把动物饼干放在丽芙·泰勒肚子上的那一幕。所以《办公室》里有两个《绝世天劫》的梗，各位。不过这就是《办公室》的精彩之处。你以为某个东西只是被提到了，然后就会想，哦，我们以后还能看到吗？接着它又被编织了回来。是的。我喜欢这样。
From the fight all the way to threat level midnight. All right, Jenna, do you have any stats for us? Well, like you mentioned earlier, Angela, the director of this movie is Michael Bay. Have you ever met Michael Bay? No. Have you? Sort of. Sort of. How do you sort of meet someone?
从《打架》一直到《危机午夜》。好了，珍娜，你有什么数据要分享吗？嗯，就像你刚才提到的，安吉拉，这部电影的导演是迈克尔·贝。你见过迈克尔·贝吗？没有。你见过吗？算见过。算见过。怎么叫算见过某人？
I can't believe I've never told you the story in all of our years of friendship. No. Okay, here's my Michael Bay story. So I was performing at Improvallympic, and then a friend of ours who also performed there, worked at a restaurant. and if we could get there before 9 p.m. he could get us like free appetizer. But then after 9, they lowered the lights and it turned into like a nightclub.
我简直不敢相信在我们的多年友谊中我从来没跟你讲过这个故事。没有。好吧，这是我的迈克尔·贝故事。当时我在即兴奥林匹克表演，然后我们的一位也在那里表演的朋友在一家餐厅工作，如果我们能在晚上9点前赶到那里，他就能给我们弄到免费开胃菜。但9点之后，他们会调暗灯光，这里就会变成一家夜总会。
What is your age? I'm like 25, 26 years old, somewhere in there. So we do our improv show and we haul ass over there so we can get in before 9. To get that free apps? Free apps. We're in a booth and it is like 9 o'clock hits.
你当时多大？我大概25、26岁，就在那个年纪。所以我们做完即兴表演，拼命赶过去，好在9点前进去。为了吃免费开胃菜？免费开胃菜。我们在一个卡座里，时间差不多到了9点。
The lights lower. And all of a sudden music's like, diz, dez, d'ez. And I'm like, oh my gosh. in walks, Michael Bay and Dan Aykroyd. No. Together. What?
灯光变暗了。突然音乐响起，咚，德兹，德兹。然后我想，噢，天哪。迈克尔·贝和丹·艾克罗伊德走了进来。不会吧。一起。什么？
With like a group of cows. Michael Bay had hair like long, wispy hair, parted on the side, kind of feathered. It was very Fabio. Very fabio. Just wispy feathered hair. Yeah. He had on a suede Western jacket with like fringe. Okay.
带着一群辣妹。迈克尔·贝梳着长而飘逸的头发，偏分，有点像羽毛状。非常法比奥。非常法比奥。就是那种飘逸的羽毛状发型。是的。他穿着一件带流苏的麂皮西部夹克。好吧。
And jeans. Okay. Is this pretty? Ormageddon or after Armageddon? Was this pre-1998 or after 1990? Pre. This is like maybe the rock. Yeah.
还有牛仔裤。好吧。这是《绝世天劫》之前还是《绝世天劫》之后？这是1998年之前还是1990年之后？之前。这大概是《石破天惊》的时候吧。是啊。
Yeah? Yeah. Okay, he comes in with Dan Aykroyd and the ladies. They sit at the booth right behind us. I am back to back with Michael Bay. Like my hair, if I tilted back, could touch his wispy hair. Yeah. And then when the music started, the gals got up.
是吗？是啊。好吧，他和丹·艾克罗伊德还有那些辣妹一起进来。他们坐在我们身后的卡座里。我和迈克尔·贝背靠背。就像我的头发，如果我往后倾斜，就能碰到他飘逸的头发。是的。然后音乐响起，辣妹们站了起来。
They were dancing. People dance too. This place turned into a club. But yeah, Michael Bay and I set back to back. Wow. Yeah. That's a nuts story. It's a nuts story. Like you're like just sitting there eating your cheese sticks and Dan Aykroyd and Michael Bay walk in. Yeah. And Michael Bay looks like a character out of like a 70s Western movie. I can't believe this story doesn't end with an explosion of some kind. Well, we had to leave because that after nine o'clock, the tables were reserved. So we got. food it out. Okay.
她们在跳舞。其他人也在跳舞。这个地方变成了一个俱乐部。但是，是的，我和迈克尔·贝背靠背坐着。哇。是的。这是一个疯狂的故事。这是一个疯狂的故事。就像你坐在那里吃奶酪条，然后丹·艾克罗伊德和迈克尔·贝走了进来。是的。而迈克尔·贝看起来就像70年代西部片里的角色。我简直不敢相信这个故事不是以某种爆炸结束的。好吧，我们不得不离开，因为过了九点，桌子都是预订的。所以我们把食物打包带走了。好吧。
But I was there long enough to see that crazy duo. That's amazing. Anyway. I'm glad we watched this movie just so I could hear that story. All right. Let's talk about the writers of this movie. In the credits at the beginning of the movie, it lists screenplay by Jonathan Hensley and J.J. Abrams. J.J. Abrams.
但我呆的时间足够长，见证了那个疯狂的二人组。太棒了。总之。我很高兴我们看了这部电影，仅仅为了听到那个故事。好吧。让我们来谈谈这部电影的编剧。在电影开头的演职员表中，编剧列出了乔纳森·汉斯雷和J·J·艾布拉姆斯。J·J·艾布拉姆斯。
Yeah. That was a surprise. But on IMDB, there are a lot of other people listed under the writing category with additional multiple titles. Yeah. I had a writing professor that said, tip of the hat, if a script went through a ton of changes, is if you have adaptation by, story by, we had all of this. In this movie. Yeah. Yeah. We had adaptation by Tony Gilroy and Shane Salerno. We had story by Robert Roy Poole and Jonathan Hensley as well. A lot of chefs here. Yeah. Well, this movie has a lot of
是的。这真是一个惊喜。但在IMDB上，编剧一栏下列出了许多其他人，有多个附加头衔。是的。我曾有一位写作教授说，如果剧本经历了一大堆修改，致敬的方式就是列出改编自、故事自，我们这里全都有。在这部电影里。是啊。是啊。我们有托尼·吉尔罗伊和谢恩·萨勒诺的改编。我们还有罗伯特·罗伊·普尔和乔纳森·汉斯雷的故事。这里有太多的厨子了。是的。好吧，这部电影有大量的
stars. Pretty much all of the men, they are Bruce Willis, Billy Bob Thornton, Ben Affleck, Will Patton Steepyshemi, Owen Wilson, Michael Clark Duncan, William Fitchner, and also Liv Tyler. I can't really imagine anyone else, but Bruce Willis in this role of Harry Stamper as the lead oil driller guy. 100%. He really held this movie together for me, but did you know that Sean Connery was originally considered for the role?
明星。几乎所有的男演员，他们是布鲁斯·威利斯、比利·鲍伯·松顿、本·阿弗莱克、威尔·帕顿、史蒂夫·布西密、欧文·威尔逊、迈克·克拉克·邓肯、威廉·菲茨纳，还有丽芙·泰勒。我真的无法想象除了布鲁斯·威利斯之外，还有谁能扮演哈里·斯坦珀这个领头石油钻井工的角色。百分之百。对我来说，他真的把这部电影撑起来了，但你知道原本考虑由肖恩·康纳利来演这个角色吗？
But Michael Bay decided to cast someone younger after meeting some actual oil drillers. surprising to me that he ever did meet real oil drillers, but okay. Oh, yeah. They did their homework. I will tell you that. Yeah. They did. They did.
但迈克尔·贝在见过一些真正的石油钻工后，决定找个年轻一点的演员。他竟然真的见过真正的石油钻工，这对我来说挺惊讶的，不过好吧。哦，是的。他们做足了功课。我得这么说。是的。他们确实做了。他们做了。
They did their homework about NASA, the space program, and oil drilling, and then they were like, fuck it. They threw it all out. We learned all about it. We're going to put any of it in the movie. They did. They had, you know, had real, like, but with real drilling engineers, they had Joe Allen, who's an astronaut, like, consult.
他们关于美国宇航局、太空计划和石油钻探做了功课，然后他们就想，去他的吧。他们把这一切都抛到脑后了。我们了解了这一切。我们才不要把任何这些放进电影里呢。他们确实这么做了。他们有，你知道的，有真正的，但和真正的钻井工程师一起，他们请来了宇航员乔·艾伦作为顾问。
And Ben Affleck, like, will say in the DVD, we use some of it. You know what I mean? I mean, it's very funny to me because so much of the first third of the movie is just them explaining why they're going to do things that make actually no sense in real life. No sense. Also, Jerry Bruckheimer shares that they offered this role to live Tyler five times before she accepted it. It was on the fifth time that she finally was like, other actors have been added by that point, Billy Bob, you know, and she was like, okay. I thought she was great. I did too. I actually really liked her. I know. Bradley Cooper auditioned for the role of A.J. Frost. Can't imagine anyone but Ben Affleck.
本·阿弗莱克在DVD中会说，我们用了一部分。你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，这对我来说非常有趣，因为电影的前三分之一很大一部分只是他们在解释他们为什么要这样做，而这些在现实生活中根本说不通。完全说不通。另外，杰瑞·布鲁克海默分享说，他们向丽芙·泰勒提供了五次这个角色，她才接受。正是在第五次时，她终于觉得，其他演员那时候都已经加盟了，比利·鲍伯什么的，然后她就想，好吧。我觉得她演得很好。我也这么觉得。我其实挺喜欢她的。我知道。布莱德利·库珀曾为A·J·弗罗斯特这个角色试镜。无法想象除了本·阿弗莱克还有谁。
I know. I don't know. I thought everybody was very well cast in this movie. Same. Incidentally, the budget for this film, I watched this movie with my son and after the first sequence in New York, he said, how much did this movie cost? It cost $140 million. In the U.S. and Canada, it made $201.5 million at the box office and the gross worldwide.
我知道。我不知道。我觉得这部电影里的每个人选角都很好。同感。顺便说一下，这部电影的预算，我和我儿子一起看的这部电影，在纽约的第一场戏之后，他说，这部电影花了多少钱？它花费了1.4亿美元。在美国和加拿大，它在票房上获得了2.015亿美元，全球总票房
was $553.7 million. So it made its money back and then some. Okay. So it was a hit. It was a hit at the box office. Angela, what did the critics have to say? Well, they have a lot to say. I'm just going to share basically Roger Ebert,
是5.537亿美元。所以它不仅收回了成本，还赚了。好吧。所以它是一部热门大片。它是一部票房大片。安吉拉，影评人们是怎么说的？嗯，他们有很多话要说。我基本上只分享罗杰·伊伯特的观点，
who gave it one star. I'm quoting him. He said, The movie is an assault on the eyes that ears the brain. Common sense. and the human desire to be entertained, he also went on to say the plot covers many of the same basis as the recent Deep Impact,
他只给了一星。我引用他的话。他说，这部电影是对眼睛、耳朵、大脑的攻击。常识。以及人类被娱乐的渴望，他还接着说，这个情节涵盖了最近的《天地大冲撞》的许多相同基础，
which compared with Armageddon, belongs on the American Film Institute list. Michael Bay did take some issue with Deep Impact. Oh, Deep Impact was like a whole thing. It had just come out. Two giant movies about asteroids hurling themselves towards Earth. Yeah, I watch some of the press junket
相比之下，《绝世天劫》应该列入美国电影学会的黑名单。迈克尔·贝确实对《天地大冲撞》有些意见。哦，《天地大冲撞》就像是一件大事。它刚刚上映。两部关于小行星冲向地球的巨作。是的，我看了其中的一些新闻发布会
of the actors promoting this. This movie, yes, and they kept getting asked about deep impact. Oh, my God. And you can just see how pissed they are. Interestingly enough, I had read that as well about Roger Ebert, hating it. I believe he lists it as the movie. He hates more than any other movie. In his compilation list, it's at the very bottom of like every movie he's ever seen in his whole life.
演员们在宣传这部电影，是的，他们一直被问及《天地大冲撞》。噢，天哪。你可以看出他们有多恼火。有趣的是，我也读到过罗杰·伊伯特如何痛恨它。我相信他将其列为他最痛恨的电影。在他的汇总清单里，它排在他一生看过的所有电影的最底部。
He really, really hated this movie. Gene Siskel, on the other hand, gave it a thumbs up. Did they hate each other? other? Did the two of them made each other? I don't know. Is that Siskel punking Ebert? Because he knows how he hated it? I don't know. Just to get under his skin, I'm not sure. But yeah, he said that he found that the sensory overload actually became bizarrely audacious and amusing. Huh. Well, you know, Michael Bay was quoted as saying in an interview that the whole movie, they shot in 16 weeks, he said it was a massive undertaking. And it wasn't fair to the movie. He said he said,
他是真的、真的很讨厌这部电影。相比之下，吉恩·西斯克尔却给出了大拇指朝上的评价。他们互不顺眼吗？他们两个互相看不顺眼吗？我不知道。那是西斯克尔在捉弄伊伯特吗？因为他知道伊伯特有多讨厌它？我不知道。只是为了惹恼他，我不确定。但，是的，他说他发现这种感官过载实际上变得怪异地大胆且有趣。呵。好吧，你知道，迈克尔·贝在一次采访中透露，整部电影他们用了16周拍摄，他说这是一项巨大的工程。这对电影不公平。他说他曾说过，
he would like to redo the entire third act if he could because the studio literally took the movie away from him. He said it was terrible. He said his visual effects supervisor had a nervous breakdown. I'm not surprised. I know. So then he had to take charge. He said he actually called James Cameron and said, what do you do when you're doing all the
如果可以的话，他想重拍整个第三幕，因为制片厂直接把电影从他手里夺走了。他说这太糟糕了。他说他的视觉特效总监精神崩溃了。这我倒不意外。我知道。所以他不得不亲自掌权。他说他甚至打电话给詹姆斯·卡梅隆，问当所有特效都得自己做时你该怎么办？但后来他结束采访时说，不过这部电影表现还行。所以，好吧。烂番茄新鲜度是43%，但爆米花指数
effects by yourself? But then he ended, the interview was saying, but the movie did fine. So, okay. It got 43% on the Rotten Tomatoes Tomatoes Tomatoes tomato meter, but a. 73% on the popcorn meter. Folks liked it. Okay. So this really tracks for me about this movie.
是73%。大家挺喜欢它的。好吧。所以这真的很符合我对这部电影的感受。因为当我看着这部电影时，首先你发短信给我。我说，这是我这辈子看过的最烂的电影。我不知道我怎么能把它看完。但随着剧情推进，我发现
I became very fascinated by the film's award nominations because it was nominated for four Academy Awards, Best Sound Effects, Editing, Best Visual Effects, and Best Original Song by Diane Warren, I Don't Want to Miss a Thing. Performed by Aerosmith. But then it also got nominated for seven Razzie Awards. It was nominated for Worst Picture, worst actor Bruce Willis, worst on-screen couple Ben Affleck and Liv Tyler,
自己说，我他妈太爱这部电影了。是的。所以我既讨厌它又觉得它烂透了，但我也觉得这是有史以来最棒的电影之一。我猜了好几次是哪些部分扭转了你对它的看法。是的，这真是一段心路历程。是的，因为我一开始也很讨厌它。然后你爱上它了吗？我爱上了。它让我想起我喜欢的那些糟糕乐队。有那么多的专辑，我知道它们很烂但我还是很爱。是啊。
worst supporting actress Liv Tyler, worst director, worst screenplay, and worst original song. Oh, no. I guess there's also something called the Stinkers Bad Movie Awards. Oh my God. Bruce Willis won. The Stinker Award.
我不知道。这其中有某种魔力。马特，你呢？对我来说它没那么经得起推敲。我觉得这次看的时候，故事感觉非常荒谬，但我确实很佩服它的规模和镜头。还有。是的。对我来说，这让我想起，我确信你见过多少糟糕的即兴表演，演员们全力投入到在舞台上出丑中？这就是它给我的感觉，就像，所有人对这事的投入程度太疯狂了。本·阿弗莱克、布鲁斯·威利斯，他们都全力以赴，就好像这是真的一样。整部电影对这个前提的投入真的令人印象深刻。它把自己
for worst actor, and Ben Affleck and Liv Tyler won a stinker for worst on-screen couple. But then, at the MTV Movie Awards, the movie was nominated for Best Movie. Liv Tyler and Ben Affleck were nominated for Best Actor and Actress and also Best On-Streen duo. Bruce Willis was also nominated for Best Actor at the Saturn Awards and the Blockbuster Entertainment Awards. He actually won that one. it was also nominated by the Japanese Academy for Best Foreign Film. And it won the Saturn Award for Best Science Fiction Film.
看得非常严肃。听着，如果那个满头飘逸长发、穿着麂皮流苏夹克的男人向你走来，他会把电影提升到另一个水平。这是那个男人拍的唯一一部电影。就是这样。他在拍一部110%的电影。他全力以赴了。是的，他称之为一部“电影”，而不是“片子”。是的，这是一部电影。我看完之后的想法是，让我想想。你斟酌字句真是太小心了。这真是一种全身心的投入。
I have to say, this really accurately summed up my feelings about the film. Because as I was watching this movie, first you texted me. And I said, this is the worst movie I've ever seen in my life. I don't know how I'm going to watch the whole thing. But then as it went on, I found, myself saying, I fucking love this movie. Yes. So I both hate it and think it's terrible, and I also think it's one of the best movies ever made.
我很累。我很累。我很欣赏所有的特效。噢，天哪。他们制作其中一些特效的方式——我们待会儿会讲到。我真的很欣赏剧组所做的工作。我真的是。是的。
I took several guesses at what the parts were that turned your viewing of it around. Yeah, it was a real journey. Yeah, because I also hated it at the start. And then did you love it? I love it. It reminds me of bad bands that I like. There's so many albums that I know are terrible that I love. Yeah.
与此同时，我再也不需要看这个了，永远不需要。但我会愿意再听一次那个DVD评论音轨。我很嫉妒你听过了。我想听，因为我待会儿会播放我找到的其中的一小段。这真让我很想听完整版。我有六个片段。太棒了。我也会在快拍里分享给任何想听的人。
I don't know. there's something about it. Matt, what about you? It didn't hold up as well for me. I feel like watching it this time, the story felt really ridiculous, but I did admire the scale and the shots of it. And yeah. Yeah. And for me, it reminded me, I'm sure how much bad improv have you seen where the actors commit to being pimped out on stage? This is what it reminded me of, like, everybody's commitment to this is insane. Ben Affleck, Bruce Willis, they all commit to this as if it's really happening. The commitment of the whole movie to the premise is really impressive. It takes itself
好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？等我们回来，我们要深入解析《绝世天劫》。好了，我们回来了。是时候解析《绝世天劫》了。这部电影将以一个充满威胁的声音开场。好吧，我们从外太空开始。是的。
very seriously. Listen, if full blown out wispy hair, suede tassel jacket man is walking up to you, he's going to take the movie to the next level. This is the only movie that man is making. This is it. He's making a 110% movie. He is all in. Yeah, and he refers to it as a film, not a movie. Yes, it's a film. My thoughts after watching it are, let's see. You're choosing your words so carefully. It was such a commitment.
我们看到了地球。是的。有什么东西正朝它呼啸而来。我们发现我们回到了恐龙时代，那颗流星在当时撞击了地球。是的。你们在这个播客的早些时候听过我们重现这段开场旁白。
I am tired. I am tired. I appreciate all the special effects. Oh, my God. The way they made some of this will get to it. I really appreciate what the crew did. I really do. Yeah.
原本是由查尔顿·赫斯顿完成的。没错。我最喜欢的事情之一就是屏幕上出现的字幕。我大声笑出来，因为它上面写着“6500万年后”。好吧，事情是这样的。他们必须为了看这部电影的13岁孩子这样做，对吧？就像是，镜头切到6500万年后。是的。
And at the same time, I don't ever need to see this again, ever. But I would listen to that DVD commentary again. I'm jealous you listen to it. I want to hear it because I'm going to play a little section of it later that I found. And it really made me want to hear the whole thing. I have six clips of it. Great. And I will also share in stories for anyone who wants to listen to it.
我们不再处于恐龙时代了。我确实很喜欢当电影片名字母出现时，它们全都炸裂开来。因为这部电影里的所有东西最终都会爆炸。包括电影片名。如果你注意的话，就在他们说“迈克尔·贝电影”之后。它爆炸了。紧接着就是一场爆炸。太完美了。
Well, listen, why do we take a break? And then when we come back, We are going to break down Armageddon. All right, we're back. It's time to break down Armageddon. This movie is going to open with a menacing voice. Well, we open an outer space. Yeah.
我们有这个叫皮特的家伙。他是个宇航员。他在飞船外面。他被其中一根绳索 tether 着。是的，他在太空中修理卫星。是的，这就是他在做的事。比利·鲍伯·松顿在任务控制中心。他说，如果你能稍微冷静一点，我送你一个水牛镍币。
We see the Earth. Yeah. Something is hurtling toward it. We find out that we're back in dinosaur times, and this meteor hit the Earth back then. Yeah. And you heard us earlier in this podcast, recreate this opening narrative.
你能为我这么做吗？他在太空中心跳加速。他们在监测他。是的。是的。而他说，嘿，伙计，我们有的是时间。所以你不用担心。哦。
that was originally done by Charlton Heston. That's right. One of my favorite things is the Chiron that comes up on the screen. I laughed out loud that it says 65 million years later. Well, here's the thing. They have to do that for the 13-year-olds watching, right? It's like, cut to 65 million years later. Yeah.
就是这样。这家伙完蛋了。是的。如果有人说“你不用担心”，你最好赶快离开那儿。你注意到皮特蓝色的眼睛了吗？注意到了。我在想，这是乔什·卢卡斯吗？这是一个年轻的乔什·卢卡斯吗？
We're not in dinosaur times anymore. I did love that when the letters of the movie come up, then they all blow apart. Because everything in this movie is going to explode eventually. including the title of the movie. And if you pay attention, it's right after they say a Michael Bay movie. It explodes. There's an immediate explosion. It's perfect.
我也这么想。我查了一下。不是。我也是。不是。是个叫伊恩·奎因的特技演员。有着最美丽的蓝眼睛。华丽。
We got this guy Pete. He's an astronaut. He's outside of the spaceship. He's tethered by one of those like cords. Yeah, he's fixing a satellite in space. Yeah, that's what he's doing. Billy Bob Thornton's back at mission control. And he's like, I'll give you a buffalo nickel if you just calm down a little bit.
华丽。他会被从天而降的东西砸中。他们一开始不知道是什么，但所有这些乱七八糟的东西开始倾泻而下。电影才开始45分钟。事情已经在爆炸了。航天飞机爆炸了。然后卫星爆炸了。所有的东西。
Can you do that for me? His heart is racing in space. They're monitoring him. Yeah. Yeah. And he's like, hey, buddy, we got plenty of time. So don't you worry. Oh.
它爆炸了。在地球上，军方认为这些是UFO。他们可能遭到攻击。抱歉，我要说这纯属胡扯。我们正从太空遭到攻击。好吧，这就是他们说的。他们说，是导弹吗？是内部故障吗？
That's it. This guy's gone. Yeah. If someone says, don't you worry, you better get the hell out of there. Did you notice Pete's blue eyes? Yes. I was like, is this Josh Lucas? Is this a young Josh Lucas?
是系统故障吗？是未知因素吗？他们为所有这些不同的场景创建了一小群人。弄清楚那是什么。我有一个DVD评论音轨的片段。我想放给你们听听关于这个开场号码的。开场号码。你管它叫什么？
I thought the same thing. I looked it up. It's not. I did too. It's not. It's a stunt actor named Ian Quinn. With the most beautiful blue eyes. Gorgeous.
开场序列。我不知道。迈克尔·贝说他雇了一个年轻的作家来重写剧本。他没有说那个人的名字。他说这个年轻人在两天内重写了53页。然后贝读了新剧本。我引用一下，
Gorgeous. He's going to get hit by something falling from the sky. They don't know what at first, but all this shit starts raining down. We're 45 seconds into the movie. Things are already exploding. The shuttle explodes. And then the satellite explodes. All of it.
迈克尔·贝说，这纯粹是狗屎。然后他给年轻作家留了这条便条——我再次引用——
It explodes. Down on Earth, the military thinks these are bogies. They could be getting attacked. I'm sorry I'm calling bullshit. We're getting attacked from space. Well, this is what they say. They said, is it missiles? Is it an internal malfunction?
在开场，你必须一把抓住观众的要害。所以这让作家重新开始工作。我怎么抓住他们的要害？然后他想出了这个，这个主意，让整个事情马上变得一团糟。好吧，现在我们要切到卡尔。他是个男人。他坐在一个，我不知道，粮仓里。他用望远镜抬头看着天空。
Is it a glitch? Is it a wild card? They create little pods of people for all of these different scenarios. Figure out what it is. I have a clip from the DVD commentary. I want to play for you guys about this opening number. Opening number. What do you call it?
他有一个自制的电报机。他有一个自制的望远镜，伙计们。他由约翰·马汉饰演，他的妻子多蒂由格蕾丝·扎布里茨基饰演，她会把门撞开，她真的很生气，因为他没有进来吃晚饭。我是说，他的施图弗锅派在桌上放了10个小时。她想要离婚。
Opening sequence. I don't know. Michael Bay said he hired a young writer to do a rewrite. He doesn't say the name of the person. He says this young guy rewrote 53 pages in two days. And then Bay read the new script. and I quote, Michael Bay said, it was pure shit. He then gave the young writer this note, and I quote again,
她气炸了。多蒂这个角色将为这部电影中的所有女性定下基调。如果你是这部电影里的女性，你要么是一个唠叨的妻子，一个脱衣舞娘，一个毫无幽默感的碧池，要么就是丽芙·泰勒。这是这部电影中女性的四种分类。干得好。
in the opening, you have to grab the audience by the balls. So this sent the writer back to work. How do I grab them by the balls? And he came up with this, this idea that this whole thing goes cibluy right away. Well, now we're going to cut to Carl. He's a man. He's sitting inside of, I don't know, a grain silo. He's looking up at the sky with a telescope.
很好的解析。谢谢。我还想说，卡尔在这部电影开头戏份如此之重，会给你一种错觉，以为他会是什么核心角色，但实际上他在仅仅几场戏之后就会永远消失。是的，我们再也没有看到他。但他的确给小行星命名了，因为我猜第一个看到并记录它的人可以给它命名。
He's got a homemade telegraph. He's got a homemade telescope, guys. He was played by John Mahon, and his wife, Doddy, played by Grace Zabritsky, is going to throw the door open, and she's really mad because he hasn't come in for dinner. I mean, his Stouffer's pot pie sat on the table for 10 hours. She wants a divorce.
他打电话给美国宇航局告诉他们这件事。他告诉了他们。他告诉比利·鲍伯·松顿，我想以我妻子多蒂的名字来命名它。然后他妻子说，哦，接着他说，因为她是一个恶毒的、吸取生命的碧池，无处可逃。是的。所以就是这样。好了，回到指挥中心，各位，这是防空警戒3级。
She's pissed. This character of Doddy is going to set the tone for all women in this film. If you are a woman in this film, you are either a shrew wife, a stripper, a bitch with no sense of humor, or live Tyler. These are the four categories of woman in this film. Well done.
还记得防空警戒吗？哦，我是说，比利·鲍伯·松顿就像是，你要叫醒11000人。我们开始吧。是的。我想提醒你们防空警戒3级意味着什么。哦，迈克尔·斯科特会非常兴奋的。是的，防空警戒3级意味着提高部队战备状态，高于正常战备状态所需水平。这意味着空军准备在15分钟内动员起来。
Good breakdown. Thank you. I'd also like to say that the fact that Carl is featured so heavily in the beginning of this movie is going to give you the impression that he's going to be some sort of central character, but he's actually going to disappear forever after just a few scenes. Yeah, we don't see him again. But he does get to name the asteroid because I guess the first person that sees it and clocks it gets to name it.
在美国的历史上，我们只有在少数几次情况下达到过防空警戒3级。一次是在1962年的古巴导弹危机期间，在1973年的赎罪日战争期间，以及在9·11袭击期间。顺便说一下，在电影中，我们在《红潮风暴》和《独立日》中达到了防空警戒3级。嗯嗯。还有《战争游戏》。好吧。
He calls NASA and tells them about it. He tells him about it. He tells Billy Bob Thornton, I want to name her Dottie after my wife. And then his wife is like, oh, and then he says, because she's a vicious life-sucking bitch from which there's no escape. Yeah. So there's that. All right, back at Command Center, everyone, it's DefCon 3.
我们在《战争游戏》中达到了所有的防空警戒级别。战争游戏。太紧张了。是啊。是啊。我们现在要切到纽约市。伙计们，有个家伙在骑自行车。他带着一条狗。
Remember the Def-Con? Oh, I mean, Billy Bob Thornton is like, you're going to wake up 11,000 people. Let's get going. Yeah. I want to remind you what Def-Con 3 means. Oh, Michael Scott would be so excited. Yes, DefCon 3 means an increase in force readiness above that required for normal readiness. It means the Air Force is ready to mobilize in 15 minutes.
他们正穿过城市。是的。这是一个由埃迪·格里芬饰演的自行车信使。嗯嗯。据迈克尔·贝说，这个场面，他向电影《哥斯拉》致敬了。你们注意到了吗，伙计们？是因为埃迪·格里芬的狗要买很多吗？一些小哥斯拉玩具。
In America's history, we have been at DefCon 3 on only a few occasions. One, during the Cuban Missile Crisis in 1962, during the 1973 Yom Kippur War, and during the September 11th attack. Incidentally, in movies, we have reached Def Korn. on three in Crimson Tide and Independence Day. Mm-hmm. And also war games. Okay.
在6分33秒时，人行道上有个家伙在卖一些哥斯拉玩偶。迈克尔·贝希望你知道那只狗是专门训练来做那个动作的。运送那只狗去片场花了他2万美元。引述迈克尔·贝的话，他真的把那些玩偶撕得稀巴烂。所以。太棒了。好吧，我们不确定这里发生了什么。我们只是在纽约市的街道上体验了一下生活，然后，他妈的，大量我们仍然不太清楚是什么的东西开始从天而降砸向曼哈顿。我写道，这简直太疯狂了，太疯狂了，这个开场太疯狂了。这个纽约的场景，我猜是小行星的碎片倾泻在他们身上，拍得太好了。我其实想播放一段DVD中迈克尔·贝谈论他们是如何拍摄的片段。这里的这些特效是用汽车翻转器完成的，我们有以极高速度射过窗户的电视。这基本上就像是一个孩子进了糖果店，
We reached all the def-cons and war games. War games. So stressful. Yeah. Yeah. We are now going to cut to New York City. You guys, there's a guy riding his bicycle. He's got a dog.
决定你可以翻转和炸毁任何你想炸的东西。我们必须想出如何在白天做事的主意，在特效驱动的电影中这非常棘手，因为你必须对你的特效非常挑剔。很多特效电影都是在晚上拍摄的，那时更容易掩饰事情。我们有篮球大小的空间岩石飞进来。它不只是爆炸并扔出一辆汽车。
They're making the way through the city. Yes. This is a bike messenger played by Eddie Griffin. Mm-hmm. Per Michael Bate, this scene, he gave a nod to the movie Godzilla. Did you catch it, guys? Is it because Eddie Griffin's dog is going to buy a lot? some little Godzilla toys.
它会夷平整个街区。这就是这些东西以每小时30,000英里的速度飞进来的速度。在这里的中央车站，我让做《泰坦尼克号》的罗伯·莱加托来拍摄这些镜头。这是一个16英尺宽的模型，上面有中央车站的照片和绿幕群众。这里有很多非常危险的特技，这些人就在飞行汽车周围，我们发明了一个相当准确的翻转系统，
There's a guy selling some Godzilla dolls on the sidewalk at six minutes and 33 seconds. Michael Bay wants you to know that dog was trained special to do that. It cost him $20,000 to ship that dog to set. And quote from Michael Bay, he really did rip the shit out of those dolls. So. Amazing. Well, we're not sure what's happening here. We're just getting a little slice of life on the streets of
我能够把人置于非常非常……靠近这些汽车的地方。我们实际上在四天内拍摄了这段纽约序列，这拍摄量相当大。好吧，这个场景赢得了MTV电影奖的最佳动作序列奖。我信。实至名归。实至名归。所以现在在电影中我们知道了是怎么回事。是一场流星雨。但结束了吗？来自NASA的引述，我们NASA有11000人在试图弄清楚这一点。在10分26秒处，我确实找到了一个背景彩蛋，迈克尔·贝把自己放进了电影里。我看到了。我知道。
New York City, and then, holy shit, tons of what we still don't quite know what start raining down from the sky hitting Manhattan. I wrote, this is literally insane, insane, this opening is insane. This New York scene where I guess parts of the asteroid are pouring down on them was done so well. I actually want to play a clip from the DVD of Michael Bay talking about how they did it. These effects right here were on car flippers and we had TVs that were shooting. through the window at high rates of speed. And this was basically being a kid in a candy store,
他在试图弄明白。他是NASA的员工之一。不过有趣的是，对于参观现实生活中的NASA太空中心，他是这么说的。我们听听。在与NASA的人会面时，我意识到他们是简单的人。他们极其聪明。他们是非常美式风格的人。NASA一点也不圆滑。
deciding you can flip and blow up whatever you want. And we had to come up with ideas how to do things in daylight, which is very tricky in effects-driven movies because you've got to be very critical on your effects. A lot of effects movies are done at night, where it's easier to disguise things. We had small basketball size space rocks coming in. It wouldn't just blow and throw a car.
我的意思是，基本上，它闻起来就像你妈妈在50年代使用的旧电视机的显像管。我绝对是认真的。旧的任务控制中心是你见过最不性感的场所，你根本无法相信他们实际上在那里把一个人送上了月球。我试图对NASA做的是让它变得性感，让人觉得最优秀、最聪明的人会在这家设施里。而在现实中，他们确实拥有最优秀和最聪明的人，但设备看起来已经过时了。
It would level city blocks. That's how fast these things come in at 30,000 miles an hour. Here in the Grand Central Station, I had Rob Legato, who did Titanic do these shots. This was a model that was 16 feet wide, and there were photographs of Grand Central Station with green-screen people. There were a lot of very dangerous stunts done here, and these are people around flying cars, and we invented a flipper system that was quite accurate,
但最优秀和最聪明的人看起来非常像比利·鲍伯。我的意思是，这些就是我在NASA遇到的人。他们是数学家，他们是科学家。他们很瘦弱。我的意思是，你看到的宇航员，他们不是那种肌肉猛男。他们是小个子。你知道，他们不是你在电影《太空先锋》里看到的那些人。宇航员只是，他们是科学家。
and I was able to put people in very very... close proximity to these cars. And we shot this New York sequence literally in four days, and that's quite a bit of shooting. Well, this scene won the MTV Movie Award for Best Action Sequence. I believe it. Well deserved. Well deserved. So now in the movie we know what is going on. It's a meteor shower. But is it over? Quote from NASA, we have 11,000 people at NASA trying to figure that out. I do have a background catch for us at 10 minutes and 26 seconds, Michael Bay put himself in the movie. I saw it. I know.
宇航员是科学家。我希望那是这部电影的宣传标语。我希望《绝世天劫》的海报上写着。我们让NASA变得性感了。我是说，伙计们，我一直把这个藏在心里。这绝对不是他最后一次提到我们不性感。噢，天哪，我得听完整段。你真的得听。
He's trying to figure it out. He's one of the NASA employees. Interestingly enough, though, here's what he had to say about visiting the real life NASA Space Center. Let's hear it. In meeting with the people at NASA, I realize that they're simple guys. They're extremely smart. They're very Americana guys. NASA's not slick in any way.
这是值得的。我们去公路旅行然后只听这个吧。好的。好吧，这就是我们要发现的。最后，这是一句台词。这是一颗得克萨斯州大小的小行星。
I mean, basically, it smells like the tubes from your mom's old TV set she had in the 50s. I'm dead serious. The old mission control is the most unsexy place you've ever seen, and you cannot believe that they actually landed a guy on the moon there. What I try to do with NASA was to sexy it up, to think the best and the brightest are going to be at this facility. And in reality, they do have the best in the brightest, but the equipment seems antiquated.
它是全球杀手。人类的终结。它撞击哪里并不重要。没有什么能幸存。连细菌都不能。我们在它撞击地球前还有18天。好吧，伙计们。事情变得真实了。
But the best in the brightest look very much like Billy Bob. I mean, these are the people that I met at NASA. They're mathematicians, they're scientists. They're slight. I mean, the astronauts you saw, they're not studly. They're little guys. You know, they're not the guys you saw in the movie of the right stuff. Astronauts are just, they're scientists.
但最优秀、最聪明的人看起来很像比利·鲍勃。我的意思是，这些是我在NASA遇到的人。他们是数学家，他们是科学家。他们很瘦弱。我的意思是，你看到的宇航员，他们并不魁梧。他们都是小个子。你知道的，他们不是你在电影《太空先锋》里看到的那些人。宇航员就是，他们是科学家。
Astronauts are scientists. I wish that was the tag in this movie. I wish the posters in Armageddon. We made NASA sexy. I mean, you guys, I've been holding on to that. That's not the last time he's going to mention the unsexiness of us. Oh, my God, I have to listen to this whole thing. You really do.
宇航员就是科学家。我希望这是这部电影的标语。我希望是《绝世天劫》海报上的标语。我们让NASA变得性感了。我的意思是，伙计们，我一直记着这件事。这不会是他最后一次提到我们不够性感。天哪，我得听完全部。你真的得听。
It is worth it. We go on a road trip and just listen to it. Yes. Please. Okay. Well, here is what we're going to find out. Finally, this is a quote. This is an asteroid the size of Texas.
这是值得的。我们去公路旅行然后就听这个。是的。拜托。好吧，接下来我们要知道的是。最后，这是一句台词。这是一个德克萨斯州大小的小行星。
It's a global killer. The end of mankind. It doesn't matter where it hits. Nothing will survive. Not even bacteria. We have 18 days before it hits Earth. All right, guys. Shit just got real.
这是一个全球毁灭者。人类的终结。无论它撞击哪里都无所谓。没有任何东西能幸存。连细菌都活不了。我们还有18天时间它就会撞击地球。好了，伙计们。事情变得严重了。
So now we're going to meet the actual cast of this. movie, forget about bike messenger guy and his dog. Forget about Carl and Dottie. You're never going to see them again. We're going to cut to an oil rig in the South China Sea where we meet Bruce Willis, a.k.a. Harry Stamper, and he's playing golf. He's hitting golf balls off a rig at the Greenpeace boat. Who's protesting the rig.
所以现在我们要去见这部电影的真正演员了，别管那个骑自行车的信使和他的狗了。别管卡尔和多蒂了。你们再也见不到他们了。我们要切到一个南海的石油钻井平台上，在那里我们遇到了布鲁斯·威利斯，也就是哈里·斯坦珀，他正在打高尔夫球。他把钻井平台上的高尔夫球击向绿色和平组织的船。那个船正在抗议这个钻井平台。
Yes. Yes. We also meet Ben Affleck, who's A.J. He works on the rig. Yeah, he's gone rogue, right? Yeah, can't find him. Well, he did something with number two, whatever that is. Pump number two. He turned it on when he wasn't supposed to.
没错。是的。我们还遇到了本·阿弗莱克，他饰演A.J.。他在钻井平台上工作。是的，他失控了，对吧？是的，找不到他。嗯，他对2号机组做了一些事情，不管那是什么。2号泵。他在不该开的时候把它打开了。
That's right. And Bruce Willis is now pissed and looking for him. Yeah. Guess what? He's been working on this rig for five years. When is Bruce Willis going to trust his gut? You know, AJ has a gut, and he thinks that pump number two is fine. Yeah.
没错。布鲁斯·威利斯现在很生气，正在找他。是的。你猜怎么着？他在这座钻井平台上工作了五年。布鲁斯·威利斯什么时候才能相信自己的直觉？你知道，AJ有直觉，他认为2号泵没问题。是的。
And they get in a little argument about it. And this is when Bruce Willis discovers that his daughter played by live Tyler is sleeping with AJ. She's in his bed. Yeah, and he is not happy about that. So he's going to get a gun. Mm-hmm. And he is going to start firing a gun on an oil rig.
他们为此争论了一番。就在这时，布鲁斯·威利斯发现由丽芙·泰勒饰演的女儿正在和AJ睡觉。她在他的床上。是的，他对此很不高兴。所以他去拿了一枪。嗯哼。他要在石油钻井平台上开枪了。
This is like a big gun. It's like a shotgun. Is this safe? This feels unsafe for so very many reasons. Well, I can tell you, as I watched this movie with my dad, who's a drilling engineer, this was the first moment in the movie that he turned to me and he said, never happened. They were going to happen. Right?
这就像是一把大枪。就像是一把猎枪。这安全吗？出于各种原因，这让人感觉很不安全。嗯，我可以告诉你，当我跟我爸一起看这部电影时，他是一名钻井工程师，这是电影中他转过头对我说“绝对不可能发生”的第一个时刻。它们根本不会发生。对吧？
He called BS on it. I found an article on mailmagine.com where they had three drilling engineers fact-checked this movie. Let me tell you, they shared my dad's sentiment. One of them said, no way would you fire a gun on a rig. It would ricochet off of everything. Yeah. Well, it did do that in the movie.
他斥之为无稽之谈。我在mailmagine.com上找到了一篇文章，里面有三位钻井工程师对这部电影进行了事实核查。让我告诉你，他们的看法和我爸的不谋而合。其中一人说：“在钻井平台上开枪是绝对不可能的。子弹会从所有东西上反弹回来。”是的。嗯，电影里确实是这样的。
I mean, there was a lot of ricochet. A lot of ricochet, something ricochets into Ben Affleck's leg. Yeah. And this whole thing is stopped because a helicopter approaches. There's a lot of father-daughter tension, a lot of arguing. Grace is saying that it's her life. She can date who she likes. Ben Affleck said, you know why we had a helicopter in this movie?
我的意思是，有很多跳弹。很多跳弹，有什么东西反弹到了本·阿弗莱克的腿上。是的。整个过程因为一架直升机的接近而被打断了。父女之间有很多紧张关系，有很多争吵。格蕾丝说这是她的人生。她可以和她喜欢的人约会。本·阿弗莱克说，你知道为什么我们在电影里安排直升机吗？
Why? Because we just wanted to show everyone that we were a big movie that had a ton of money. He said it was loud. You couldn't hear your lines. But they had to have a helicopter. Yeah, these are the people who are financing this oil drill. And they're going to give them a little tour. or Liv Tyler clearly has some role in this business, family business, her dad's rig.
为什么？因为我们只想向大家展示我们是一部拥有大量资金的大制作电影。他说声音太大了。你根本听不清台词。但他们必须安排一架直升机。是的，这些人是这个石油钻井项目的金主。他们要带他们参观一下。丽芙·泰勒在这个商业里显然扮演着某种角色，家族企业，她爸爸的钻井平台。
It's like she's like the sort of marketing PR person. Like, look, this is what you're spending your money on. She's now in a nice black dress. She's in high heels on a rig. Right. Right. Yeah. She's showing off everything that's happening.
就好像她是那种营销公关人员。就像，看，这就是你们花钱的地方。她现在穿着一件漂亮的黑色礼服。她在钻井平台上穿着高尔夫鞋。对的。对的。是的。她正在展示正在发生的一切。
But we're also going to cut to a lot of problem solving meetings over at NASA. And they're trying to figure out how are we going to stop this giant meteor? And there's this great scene. where they explain, oh, we should just have a nuclear bomb go off. Just shoot a nuclear bomb at it. And the guy is like, no. You have to drill a bomb into the middle. Because imagine if you held a firecracker in your open hand and it went off, it would burn your hand.
但我们也会切换到许多在NASA召开的问题解决会议。他们试图弄清楚我们该如何阻止这个巨大的流星？这里有一个很棒的场景。他们解释说，哦，我们应该让一枚核弹爆炸。直接向它发射一枚核弹。然后那个人说，不。你必须把炸弹钻进中间。因为想象一下，如果你把一个鞭炮放在你张开的手心里，然后它爆炸了，它会烧伤你的手。
But if you close your fist around the firecracker and it goes off, it'll blow your hand off. Right. So this is what they have to do. They have to drill a hole and then put a nuclear bomb in the hole of the aspirational. Right. We're going to cut to the rig now. Something is wrong. They are blowing oil, mud and gas all over the rig.
但如果你把拳头握紧包裹着鞭炮让它爆炸，它会把你的手炸飞。对的。所以这就是他们必须做的。他们必须钻一个洞，然后把一枚核弹放进有抱负者的洞里。对的。现在我们要切回钻井平台。出问题了。他们把石油、泥浆和天然气喷得到处都是。
My dad turned to me and said, that would never happen. He called bullshit. I'm doing such a bad impression of my dad. But he would say never happen. According to the drilling engineers, that fact-checked this, quote one said, that's one of the things where the physics doesn't make sense. He just goes over there with a big crescent wrench and turns the valve by the standpipe.
我爸转过身对我说，那绝对不可能发生。他斥之为胡扯。我模仿我爸模仿得太烂了。但他会说绝不可能发生。根据对这一情节进行事实核查的钻井工程师所说，引用其中一位的话：“这是物理原理说不通的事情之一。”他拿着一把大活动扳手走过去，转动了立管旁的阀门。
It makes absolutely no sense. That's not how it works. You secure a well from the rig floor. You don't secure it from the corner of the Derek. But also, they all just went on and on and said there's so many safety measures now. And it's very slim that anything like that would happen. Well, for the plot, I guess this had to happen because it proves that AJ's gut was wrong about drill number two. Right.
这完全说不通。事情根本不是这样的。你得从钻井平台地面上固定油井。你不能从井架的角落去固定它。而且，他们一直在说现在有这么多的安全措施。发生这种事情的概率微乎其微。好吧，为了剧情需要，我想这必须发生，因为这证明了AJ对2号钻机的直觉是错的。对的。
Now, you guys, another helicopter is going to come. This time, it's General Montgomery. Mm-hmm. And he's going to say, you've got to come with me. It's a matter of urgent national security. Harry's like, the crazy Willie put you up to this. And the general's like, I'm afraid I don't know who crazy Willie is, sir. I'm dead serious.
好了，伙计们，又有一架直升机要来了。这次来的是蒙哥马利将军。嗯哼。他会说，你必须跟我走。这是一件刻不容缓的国家安全大事。哈里说，是不是那个疯狂的威利唆使你这么干的。将军说，恐怕我不知道疯狂的威利是谁，长官。我是认真的。
And then I think this is when Steve Buscemi's character gets the creeper award. Yeah, he gets to make a weird underage sex joke. Yeah. He comes up to Bruce Willis when he sees the helicopter and he says, I swear, I didn't know how old she was. This is going to be the beginning of the creeper runner. That is Steve Buschemy's character. Yeah. And Harry's like, fine, I'll go, but I want to take my daughter because he's wanting to get her
然后我想这就是史蒂夫·布西密的角色获得“怪蜀黍”奖的时候了。是的，他开了一个奇怪的未成年人性爱玩笑。是的。他看到直升机时走到布鲁斯·威利斯面前说，我发誓，我不知道她多大。这将是“怪蜀黍”戏份的开始。那是史蒂夫·布西密的角色。是的。哈里说，好吧，我去，但我要带上我的女儿，因为他想把她
away from AJ. Yeah. So they arrive in Houston. Harry Stamper meets Dan Truman. And after a kind of rough hello, they go inside and they bring Harry up to speed. If you are wondering why the entire world is not in a massive panic right now, it's because they're going to tell us. There are only nine telescopes in the world that can see this asteroid.
从AJ身边带走。是的。于是他们到达了休斯敦。哈里·斯坦珀见到了丹·杜鲁门。在经历了一次有些生硬的问候后，他们走了进去，向哈里通报了最新情况。如果你想知道为什么全世界现在没有陷入巨大恐慌，那是因为他们要告诉我们了。世界上只有九架望远镜能看到这颗小行星。
and the U.S. controls eight of them. So they're able to keep this a secret from the whole world, even though most of New York City has been destroyed by a meteor shower. No one's looking up in the sky except for us. That's right. Bruce Willis has maybe one of my favorite lines in the movie. He says, six billion people on the planet, why'd you guys call me? By the way, in terms of people looking up at the sky,
而美国控制了其中八架。所以他们能够向全世界隐瞒这个秘密，尽管纽约市的大部分地方已经被流星雨摧毁了。除了我们，没有人抬头看天空。没错。布鲁斯·威利斯在电影里有一句我最喜欢的台词。他说，地球上有六十亿人，你们为什么偏偏叫我？顺便说一句，就人们抬头看天空而言，
I googled how far, because the asteroids, it's the size of Texas. Hypothetically, NASA would know about that decades to centuries before impact, not 18 days. Also, now since the scene is back in the NASA Space Center, Michael Bay had more to say about NASA and its building. Let's hear it. At NASA here, we tried to sexy it up. This is not a building. This is actually this building sells herbal products.
我用谷歌搜索了距离，因为小行星，它有得克萨斯州那么大。假设NASA在撞击发生前几十到几百年就会知道这件事，而不是18天。另外，既然场景回到了NASA太空中心，迈克尔·贝对NASA及其建筑有更多的话要说。我们听听看。这里的NASA，我们试图把它拍得更有魅力。这不是一栋建筑。实际上，这栋建筑售卖草本产品。
If you saw the real NASA, you just wouldn't trust it as far as you can throw it. It looks very much like an old 60s, 50s kind of school. I was very unimpressed when I went to NASA, just in terms of just the look and the lack of design. But I was also very impressed with just the intelligent people that I met there and the systems that they're doing. So we tried to give NASA a look in our mission control that was stately. I was creating a NASA that would, what would my perception of NASA be? Amazing. You guys, I'm telling you, could you not listen to that all day?
如果你看到真正的NASA，你根本无法对它产生一丝信任。它看起来非常像一所60年代、50年代的学校。当我参观NASA时，我非常失望，无论从外观还是缺乏设计感来看。但我也对我在那里遇到聪明的人以及他们正在进行的系统印象深刻。所以我们试图让NASA在我们的任务控制中心看起来庄严。我创造了一个NASA，我的NASA认知会是什么样？太棒了。伙计们，我告诉你们，你们难道不想一整天都听这个吗？
Yeah. And look, I'm not kink shaming. I know there's a kink out there for everyone. Everybody, this is the first time I've ever seen anybody be horny for NASA, just as the building itself. Well, not the original building. Yeah, exactly. So now they're going to take Harry down to this airplane hanger and they're going to show him this drill. It's a drill that they stole from him.
对的。听着，我不是在对性癖指手画脚。我知道每个人都有自己的性癖。各位，这是我第一次见到有人对NASA产生性欲，仅仅是对建筑物本身。嗯，不是原建筑。对，没错。现在他们要把哈里带到这个飞机库里，向他展示这个钻头。这是他们从他那里偷来的钻头。
His plans that were patented. They stole it from him eight months ago for a Mars project and it's not working right. And they need him to fix it so that they can take it into space so they, they can drill into this asteroid. And they have these eight astronauts that they've been training to use the drill and they're messing it up. And this leads to Ben Affleck's famous DVD commentary about this scene. Let's hear it. I asked Michael why it was easier to train oil drillers to become astronauts than it was to train astronauts to become oil drillers.
他的申请了专利的图纸。八个月前，他们为了一个火星项目把它偷走了，但它现在运行得并不好。他们需要他来修理它，以便把它带到太空去，让他们能够钻入这颗小行星。他们有八名一直在训练使用这个钻头的宇航员，但他们把事情搞砸了。这就引出了本·阿弗莱克关于这个场景的著名的DVD评论。我们听听看。我问迈克尔，为什么把石油钻井工人训练成宇航员，比把宇航员训练成石油钻井工人更容易。
And he told me to shut the fuck up. So that was the end of that talk. He was like, you know, Ben, just shut up. Okay, you know, this is a real plan, all right? I was like, you mean it's a real plan at NASA to train oil drillers? He was like, just shut your mouth. See, here's where we demonstrate that, because Bruce is going to tell the guys that they did a bad job of building the drill tank.
他让我闭上他妈的嘴。所以那次谈话就到此为止了。他当时说，你知道的，本，闭嘴吧。好吧，你知道，这是一个真正的计划，对吧？我当时说，你是说NASA训练石油钻井工人的计划是认真的？他当时说，闭上你的臭嘴。看，这就是我们展示这一点的地方，因为布鲁斯要告诉大家，他们把钻井车建得很烂。
He did a piss. See, he's a salt-of-the-earth guy, and the NASA nerdanauts don't understand his salt-of-the-earth ways, his rough-and-tumble ways. Yeah, that's right. Well, that's because your cans are all... Like, somehow they can build rocket ships, but they don't understand, like, what makes a good tranny. We've had some training for eight months solid now.
他做得一塌糊涂。你看，他是一个脚踏实地的人，而NASA的书呆子们并不理解他脚踏实地的作风，他那粗犷不羁的作风。是的，没错。好吧，那是因为你们的罐子全都……就好像不知何故他们可以建造火箭，但他们却不明白什么才叫好的变速箱。我们现在已经进行了整整八个月的训练。
Eight whole months? Well, pretty much, yeah. Oh, gee, weird. Like, eight whole months, as if that's not enough time to learn how to drill a hole, but in a week, we're going to learn how to be astronauts. A one hole week? Now you know how to fly into space? I need my guys. Why do you need them?
整整八个月？嗯，差不多吧，是的。哦，天哪，真奇怪。就像整整八个月一样，好像那还不足以学会如何钻孔，但在一周之内，我们要学会如何成为宇航员。整整一个星期？现在你知道怎么飞向太空了？我需要我的人。你为什么需要他们？
They're the best. Everyone's the best. Why are they the best? I don't know. They just are. I'm only the best because I work with the best. You don't trust the men you're working with. You're as good as dead. You want to send these boys into space, fine. I'm sure they'll make good astronauts. They don't know Jack about drilling.
他们是最棒的。每个人都是最棒的。为什么他们是最棒的？我不知道。他们就是。我之所以是最棒的，是因为我和最棒的人共事。如果你不信任与你共事的男人，你离死就不远了。你想把这些小伙子送上太空，好吧。我确信他们会成为优秀的宇航员。他们对钻探一无所知。
I mean, this is a little bit of a logic stretch. Let's face it. They don't know Jack about drilling. How hard can it be? Aim the drill at the ground and turn it on. You think it's just drilling a hole? There's a lot you're going to know about, and when you're going to break snap off an edge in a tranny on a corner of a hot pipe and you're going to get a gas pocket. Like, yeah, well, what about when the booster rockets don't fire and your EVA suit and your zero gravity?
我的意思是，这有点违背逻辑。让我们面对现实吧。他们对钻探一无所知。这能有多难？把钻头对准地面并打开它。你以为这只是钻个洞？你要了解的东西有很多，当你把边缘折断在热管角落的变速箱里时，你会遇到一个气穴。就像，是的，好吧，当助推火箭没有点火、而你穿着舱外宇航服处于失重状态时又会怎么样？
You know, didn't you see a bottle 13, boy? You guys, this commentary is one of the best things I've heard in a long time. I do want to say something, though. I want to say I completely agreed with Ben Affleck's take. in this moment. But when they got up there and they were drilling that hole, I did feel like they needed
你知道，难道你没看过《阿波罗13号》吗，孩子？伙计们，这段评论是我这段时间听到的最棒的事情之一。不过我想说一件事。我想说我完全赞同本·阿弗莱克在这场戏中的看法。但当他们到达那里并开始钻孔时，我确实觉得他们需要
some drilling experts. Well, the drilling engineers that were interviewed for that article, they were proposed this question, would it be easier to take an astronaut and train them to be a drilling engineer or get the drilling engineers out into space? Yeah.
一些钻探专家。好吧，接受那篇文章采访的钻探工程师们，他们被提出了这个问题：把宇航员训练成钻探工程师更容易，还是把钻探工程师送上太空更容易？是的。
Listen, they didn't have to fly. No, they had pilots. They were passengers. Yeah. So they were all like, no, it's just you've got to know so much about like geology and like all the pressure and all of that. And it takes years and years. I think they were right to take the drilling engineers up into space. Ultimately, I do. I mean,
听着，他们不必飞行。不，他们有飞行员。他们是乘客。是的。所以他们都觉得，不，你必须了解很多关于地质学以及所有压力之类的事情。这需要长年累月的积累。最终我觉得他们把钻探工程师送上太空是正确的。我确实这么认为。我的意思是，
they didn't have to learn how to be astronauts. They just had to learn to like get to space. Get to space. Bruce Willis is like, he's going to do it, but he needs his own men. He needs real drillers. So now we have our let's assemble the team montage. Boy, you. You know, You guys, these drilling engineers, they're all over the place. They're riding motorcycles. They're getting tattoos. One of them's being creepy in a bar. One's on horseback.
他们不需要学习如何成为宇航员。他们只需要学会如何去太空。去太空。布鲁斯·威利斯说，他会去，但他需要他自己的人。他需要真正的钻井工人。所以现在我们有了“组装团队”的蒙太奇。天哪，你。你知道的，伙计们，这些钻井工人无处不在。他们骑着摩托车。他们纹身。其中一个在酒吧里行为诡异。一个在骑马。
One's betting in Vegas. And AJ, we find, has started his own drilling business. It's so sad looking. It has like a wooden sign that he's gray painted. Like, AJ's drilling on it. It looks like a homemade lemonade stand. Jenna, I got to ask, is this the scene that turned the movie around for you? No.
一个在拉斯维加斯下注。我们发现，AJ已经开始了自己的钻井业务。看起来太凄凉了。它有一个用灰色油漆刷过木制招牌。上面写着“AJ钻井”。这看起来像是一个自制的柠檬水摊。詹娜，我得问问，这就是那个让这部电影在你心中扭转乾坤的场景吗？不是。
It was actually the scene before. Okay. was the scene of Bruce Willis being like, I'll do it. Because this is the moment, I found myself enjoying the movie, like smiling and realizing I had no longer hated it. I love assembling the crew montage. The thing about this one, though, is like, I was still very unclear about what the people could do.
实际上是前一个场景。好吧。是布鲁斯·威利斯说“我来”的那个场景。因为在这个时刻，我发现自己开始享受这部电影了，会心一笑，并意识到我不再讨厌它了。我喜欢组装船员的蒙太奇。不过，这个场景的问题在于，对于这些人能做什么，我仍然很不清楚。
They're like, this guy's the best. And they're like, we don't need to know what they're the best at. We don't need Owen Wilson at all. They're just the best. If she comes in Andy zero times. Yes, this is when we introduce Owen Wilson. and it's never clear to me what he's good at. Steve Bouchemey, we come to find out, is some sort of genius.
他们就像，这家伙是最棒的。然后他们又像，我们不需要知道他们到底擅长什么。我们根本不需要欧文·威尔逊。他们就是最棒的。如果她进来，安迪为零次。是的，这就是我们介绍欧文·威尔逊出场的时候。而且我从来不清楚他擅长什么。我们发现史蒂夫·布西密是个某种天才。
He is a genius. He taught at MIT. Yeah. He has multiple doctorates. And he's very useful when they get out there. And the big guy getting the tattoo operates the drill at the end. So he's relevant. Yeah.
他是个天才。他在麻省理工学院教过书。是的。他拥有多个博士学位。当他们去到太空时，他非常有用。那个纹身的大个子最后负责操作钻头。所以他是相关的。是的。
Owen Wilson is just funny sidekick material. But Harry is going to gather them all in the new sexy NASA conference room. You guys. This scene was Bruce Willis's first day of filming. Oh. He joined them a month into filming. And he tells them about the asteroid. And then he has this amazing line that they shared on the DVD commentary was improvised.
欧文·威尔逊只是个滑稽的搞笑配角材料。但哈里要把他们全都召集到那个崭新性感的NASA会议室里。伙计们。这场戏是布鲁斯·威利斯拍摄的第一天。哦。他在开拍一个月后加入了他们。他向他们讲述了小行星的事，然后他有一句在DVD评论中分享的绝妙台词是即兴发挥的。
What was it? He says, the United States government just asked us to save the world. Anybody want to say no? Oh, that's a good line. I know. Way to go, Bruce Willis. Well, they all agree to do it, but they do have some requests. They do.
是什么？他说，美国政府刚刚要求我们拯救世界。有人想说不吗？哦，这台词真棒。我知道。干得好，布鲁斯·威利斯。好吧，他们都同意这样做，但他们确实有一些要求。他们确实有。
Michael Bay said he had the actors write things down that they would want as their characters, and then Bruce read them off the pages. So there was some improv here. Michael Bay came up with the line about the no taxes. They'll never have to pay taxes again. I thought that was a really smart request. Yes, he said that got a really big cheers in the movie screenings he went to. No one wants to pay taxes.
迈克尔·贝说，他让演员们写下他们希望角色拥有的东西，然后布鲁斯照着读了出来。所以这里有一些即兴发挥。关于免税的台词是迈克尔·贝想出来的。他们再也不用交税了。我觉得这是一个非常聪明的要求。是的，他说这在他参加的电影放映会上赢得了巨大的欢呼声。没有人想交税。
One of the guys has 56 parking tickets that he would like resolved. Another person wants them to bring back eight-track tapes. Chick, the gambling guy, would like a full week's emperor's package to Caesar's Palace in Vegas. Bear wants to stay at the White House in the Lincoln bedroom for the whole summer. Interesting. Well, now it's time for another montage.
其中一个人有56张停车罚单想要被撤销。另一个人希望他们带回8轨磁带。赌徒奇克想要一份拉斯维加斯凯撒宫为期一周的皇帝套餐。贝尔想整个夏天都住在白宫的林肯卧室里。有趣。好吧，现在是另一个蒙太奇的时间。
This movie is really montages and explosions and screaming. And this is their medical psychological exam montage. What is happening in this? What is happening? They're all in hospital gowns. Yeah. Someone brings a big giant syringe with yellow liquid. What is that for?
这部电影真的全都是蒙太奇、爆炸和尖叫。这是他们的医疗心理检查蒙太奇。这演的是什么？这到底在干什么？他们都穿着医院病号服。是的。有人拿来一个装有黄色液体的大注射器。那是用来干什么的？
What is that for? Some of them have bags with IVs. Some look like they're getting, is that like an anal probe? Yeah. What? I know. Then they dance and then they fuck around with a hospital equipment. The doctor doing the anal probe is the only woman in this whole movie that has a sense
那是用来干什么的？他们有些人带着静脉输液袋。有些人看起来像是在接受，那是肛门指检吗？是的。什么？我知道。然后他们跳舞，然后瞎胡闹医院设备。做肛门指检的医生是这部电影里唯一一个有幽默感的女性。另外，这是我做的三次深度调查之一。我当时很着迷。我在想，为什么他们都要做
of humor. Also, this is one of the three mini deep dives I did. I was fascinated. I was like, why do they all get? enemas. And it's a real thing. Many astronauts receive pre-launched enemas to clear their bowels before. So they don't shit themselves? Yep. Yeah. Oh, well, there you go. There is a psychiatrist who does some type of inkblot test and a Rubik's Cube thing. Yeah. When I watched this part of the movie with Lee, he said, I can't believe this is still going on. He said this was unnecessarily long.
灌肠？这是真事。许多宇航员在发射前接受灌肠以清理肠道。这样他们就不会拉裤子了？对。是的。哦，好吧，就是这样。有一位精神科医生在做某种墨迹测试和魔方测试。是的。当我跟李一起看电影的这一部分时，他说，我真不敢相信这还在继续。他说这完全没有必要这么长。
I agree. Agree. At the end, the doctor says they failed. Sorry. They failed all. of the tests, none of them are suitable. Billy Bob Thornton says, all I need to know is that they can physically survive a trip to space. So his bar is very low. The doctor says, quote, personally, I don't know how they survived the tests, but he does approve them.
我同意。同意。最后，医生说他们失败了。抱歉。他们所有的测试都失败了，没有一个人合适。比利·鲍勃·托顿说，我只需要知道他们能在生理上挺过太空之旅就行了。所以他的标准很低。医生说，引述原话：“就我个人而言，我不知道他们是怎么通过这些测试的”，但他确实批准了他们。
He does. Now you guys, we get to see the space shuttle. And there's this whole simulation in the swimming pool in like the spacesuits. I mean, it's pretty amazing what they were able to do. Michael Bay talks about it. They actually shot in the NASA weightless simulation tank that you see in the scene. So they shot in the actual pool?
他确实批准了。现在，伙计们，我们可以看到航天飞机了。还有穿着宇航服在游泳池里的整个模拟训练。我的意思是，他们能够做到这一点真是太了不起了。迈克尔·贝谈到了这一点。他们实际上是在你在场景中看到的NASA失重模拟水箱里拍摄的。所以他们是在真正的水池里拍摄的？
Yes. In the suit that Ben Affleck's wearing that they shot in was a million dollars. And later, when we get to the actual launch, they were able to have access there and shoot as well. Pretty amazing. Wow. Well, there's a couple things we learn, by the way, in the scene. First of all, this is a brand new shuttle. And it has a special armor on it, everybody.
是的。本·阿弗莱克穿的那套拍摄用的宇航服价值一百万美元。后来，当我们真正发射时，他们也得以进入现场进行拍摄。太惊人了。哇。好吧，顺便说一句，我们在这一幕中了解到几件事。首先，这是一艘全新的航天飞机。每个人注意，它有特殊的装甲。
And it's new. And this is why later, when this shuttle is being pummeled by various things in space and it's not breaking, it's because it's special. Okay? The main pilot is played by William Fitchner. And his co-pilot is a female pilot who was played by Jessica Steen. She is the only woman besides Liv Tyler in this movie in a major role. And in her main scene where she speaks, she's trying to describe crucial information about their space suits.
而且它是崭新的。这就是为什么后来当这艘航天飞机在太空中遭到各种东西的狂轰滥炸却依然没有破损时，是因为它很特别。好吗？主要飞行员由威廉·菲德内尔饰演。他的副驾驶是一位女飞行员，由杰西卡·斯廷饰演。她是这部电影中除了丽芙·泰勒之外唯一扮演主要角色的女性。在她主要说话的那场戏里，她试图描述关于他们宇航服的关键信息。
But behind her back, they're basically just snickering and talking about how she's hot. Yeah. They're not really listening to her. She does call them out, though. She is like, hey, I'm trying to keep you alive here. Yeah. Apples. Yes.
但在她背后，他们基本上只是在窃笑，谈论她有多性感。是的。他们并没有真正在听她说话。不过她确实回击了他们。她就像，嘿，我正努力让你们活着呢。是的。苹果。是的。
Well, this whole scene reminded me of an interview. that I once saw with the very first female mission control officer, Francis. Her nickname was Poppy Northcutt. She joined NASA's mission control in 1968 at the age of 25. She's a fucking badass. She was a mathematical analyst, and she helped to plot the return to Earth trajectory software that brings astronauts back from the moon. Amazing. She first worked on the Apollo 8 mission. She was also in Mission Control during the Apollo 13 emergency, her team figured out how to bring the astronauts home. They were awarded the Presidential Medal of Freedom Award. So I would really love for you to hear this interview with her. This is an interview from 1968 after she started working at NASA,
好吧，整个场景让我想起了一次采访，我曾经看过对第一位女性任务控制中心官员弗朗西斯的采访。她的绰号是波比·诺斯卡特。她于1968年以25岁的年龄加入NASA任务控制中心。她真他妈是个狠角色。她是一名数学分析师，她帮助绘制了将宇航员从月球带回地球的返回轨道软件。太棒了。她首先参与了阿波罗8号任务。在阿波罗3号紧急事件期间，她也在任务控制中心，她的团队弄清楚了如何将宇航员带回家。他们被授予了总统自由勋章。所以我真的很想让你们听听对她的这次采访。这是1968年她开始在NASA工作后的一次采访，
this extremely intelligent, accomplished woman. This is what the interviewer asked her. How much problem does a woman have working in a dominantly male environment like mission control? I don't think she has any problems. How much attention do men pay to a pretty girl on a miniskirt working in their midst? Not much. They're too busy with their consoles. Yeah, those are the two questions that this interviewer asked her. I'm glad he asked the NASA astronaut about a miniskirt. Are you kidding me? this woman is rad.
这位极其聪明、成就非凡的女性。这就是采访者问她的问题。女性在一个以男性为主导的环境（比如任务控制中心）中工作会有多大的麻烦？我认为她没有任何麻烦。男人们对一个在他们中间工作的穿着迷你裙的漂亮女孩有多关注？没多少。他们太忙于他们的控制台了。是的，这就是这位采访者问她的两个问题。我很高兴他问了这位NASA宇航员关于迷你裙的事。你在开玩笑吗？这个女人太酷了。
So I got completely fascinated and I read a bunch about her. And one of the things that she also talked about was that the pay grade was so different for men versus women. And they wanted her to be in this very important position, but they had no category to pay a woman the salary that she would deserve. Yes. And so they had to create this new system just. for her. And she said, this whole experience made her a feminist and made her fight for the Equal Rights Amendment and fight for equal pay for women in the workplace. She also helped to pass a law that prohibited hospitals from charging women who came in for a rape kit. And then in 1984, she graduated Summa Cum Laude from the University of Houston Law Center and became a criminal defense lawyer.
所以我完全被迷住了，读了许多关于她的文章。她谈到的事情之一是男女薪酬等级差异巨大。他们希望她担任这个非常重要的职位，但他们没有给女性支付应得薪水的类别。是的。所以他们不得不专门为她创建这个新系统。她说过，这段经历使她成为了一名女权主义者，并促使她为《平等权利修正案》奋斗，为职场女性同工同酬而战。她还帮助通过了一项法律，禁止医院向前来做强奸检查的女性收费。然后，在1984年，她以优异成绩从休斯顿大学法学院毕业，并成为了一名刑事辩护律师。
Once again, her name is Poppy Northcut and she's totally awesome. I mean, what a badass. What a total badass. All right, let's see, Ang, what is next? Well, back now at NASA, Billy Bob's character is going to explain the flight plan to them. Oh, I loved this scene. I loved this scene. He's got two little space shuttles on sticks, like the little toy space shuttles.
再次重申，她的名字叫波比·诺斯卡特，她简直棒极了。我的意思是，真是个狠角色。绝对是个狠角色。好吧，让我们看看，安，接下来是什么？嗯，现在回到NASA，比利·鲍勃的角色要向他们解释飞行计划。哦，我喜欢这场戏。我喜欢这场戏。他拿着两个插在棍子上的小航天飞机模型，就像小玩具航天飞机一样。
Yeah. And then he's got the moon, and he's going to explain this lunar gravity slingshot that they're going to need to do to come around the moon and slingshot onto the asteroid, right? Yeah. Owen Wilson's character is going to speak and say, what's it like on the asteroid if we land on it? And Billy Bob's character says 200 degrees in the sunlight, minus 200 in the shade, canyons of razor sharp rock, unpredictable gravitational conditions, unexpected eruptions, things like that. And Owen Wilson says, so the scariest environment imaginable. Thanks. Got it. Yeah. Billy Bob Thornton has the two space shuttles because, guys, they're sending up two shuttles. Yes. With two drills. and two nuclear bombs.
是的。然后他有了月球，他要解释他们绕过月球并利用引力弹弓加速冲向小行星所需的月球引力弹弓效应，对吧？是的。欧文·威尔逊的角色开口说话了，问如果我们在小行星上降落，上面是什么样的？比利·鲍勃的角色说阳光下200度，阴凉处零下200度，到处是剃刀般锋利的岩石峡谷、不可预测的引力条件、突如其来的喷发，诸如此类。欧文·威尔逊说，所以这是能想象到的最可怕的环境。谢谢。明白了。是的。比利·鲍勃·托顿拿着两个航天飞机模型，因为，伙计们，他们要发射两艘航天飞机。是的。带着两个钻头
They're going to split them up. They're going to each land on different parts of the asteroid. Whoever drills the whole first puts the nuclear bomb in, and then both shuttles will fly away. Yes, it's the freedom and the independence for our two shuttles. Right. I have a background catch because Harry is going to go looking for Grace, and he finds Owen Wilson's character just kind of playing on the PA system.
和两枚核弹。他们会把它们分开。它们将分别降落在小行星的不同部位。谁先钻好洞就把核弹放进去，然后两艘航天飞机就会飞走。是的，这是属于我们两艘航天飞机的自由与独立。对的。我注意到一个背景花絮，因为哈里去找格蕾丝，他发现欧文·威尔逊的角色正靠在公共广播系统上玩。
Mm-hmm. background catch at 45 minutes and 38 seconds. Michael Bay wants you all to know that this is the actual very unsexy real NASA control center. Oh. So there you go. Well, Harry is going to find Grace and AJ and they are sitting in a satellite? A thruster? A booster.
嗯哼。背景花絮在45分38秒。迈克尔·贝想让你们所有人知道，这是真正的、非常不性感的真实NASA控制中心。哦。所以就是这样。好吧，哈里找到了格蕾丝和AJ，他们正坐在一颗卫星里？一个推进器里？一个助推火箭里。
A wine picnic and making out. But not making out, lady, not making out. This scene was so cringy to me. He's behind her, right? And he's taking her dress strap down and then really sloppy kissing her shoulder. Yeah. That's what it is. There's no makeout.
喝着红酒野餐并亲热。但不是亲热，女士，不是亲热。这场戏让我感到非常尴尬。他站在她身后，对吧？他把她的裙子肩带拉下来，然后非常随地亲吻她的肩膀。是的。就是这样。根本不是亲热。
Yeah. Sloppy shoulder kissing. I do have a clip from Michael Bay. I would like to play for you all. Michael Bay has talked a little bit about what Ben Affleck did to get ready for the movie. They got him a personal trainer. But there was something that wasn't taken care of. And Michael Bay wanted to take care of it.
是的。随地亲吻肩膀。我确实有一个迈克尔·贝的片段。我想放给你们大家听听。迈克尔·贝谈到了本·阿弗莱克为这部电影做准备所做的一些事情。他们给他找了一个私人教练。但有些事情并没有被照顾到。而迈克尔·贝想要照顾到这一点。
Let's hear it. We paid for a set of 20,000. of pearly white teeth. Ben's going to hate that story. I always like low shots that kind of come right under your chin, just make you a little bit heroic, and he kind of had these baby teeth. So I told Jerry Bruckheimer, I said, God, he's got these baby teeth, Jerry, I don't know what to do. Jerry used a very famous star in a plane movie that he replaced teeth with. So he says, we did it to him. Why not do it to Ben? So my dentist had Ben sitting in a dentist chair for a week, eight hours a day. So basically they made Bonafelic get veneers for this?
我们听听看。我们花了一套2万美金的珍珠白牙齿。本会讨厌这个故事的。我总是喜欢那种刚好在你下巴底下的低角度镜头，能让你显得有点英勇，而他有点这种乳牙。所以我告诉杰瑞·布鲁克海默，我说，天哪，他有这些乳牙，杰瑞，我不知道该怎么办。杰瑞曾在一部飞机电影中使用过一位非常著名的明星，他换掉了那人的牙齿。所以他说，我们对他这么做了。为什么不也对本这么做呢？所以我的牙医让本在一个牙医椅上坐了一个星期，一天八小时。所以基本上他们让本·阿弗莱克为了这个做了瓷贴面？
Yes. Because he didn't like his little baby teeth. That's right. You wanted him to have big, shiny white teeth. Yes. Wait, so had they shot some of the movie with his baby teeth and some with the veneers? They must have. I mean, they shot a month before Bruce Willis got there.
是的。因为他不喜欢他那小乳牙。没错。你希望他有又大又闪亮的白牙。是的。等等，所以他们拍电影的时候有些镜头是他的乳牙，有些是贴面？一定是的。我的意思是，他们在布鲁斯·威利斯到那儿之前拍了一个月。
So there must have been, like, early in the movie, the baby teeth. Oh, I wish I'd known this. I would have tried to track it. I would have looked for baby teeth versus white teeth. I tried to look for baby teeth. I don't see them. Okay. I think whatever they shot, they were like, let's pull him and get these teeth done.
所以肯定有这样的情况，比如电影早期是乳牙。哦，我要是早知道这个就好了。我会试着追踪它的。我会寻找乳牙和白牙的区别。我试着寻找乳牙。我没看到。好吧。我想无论他们拍了什么，他们都觉得，让我们把他拉回来把牙齿做好吧。
And there's some famous actor that Jerry Bruckheimer had do this that played a pilot. I'm sure we could figure that out. I know. Well, listen, Harry doesn't interrupt this weird snuggle session, but he does get with all his guys. And the guys are like, listen, Harry, Grace has grown up. She's also a real haughty, and we all kind of raised her, and we think AJ is a great choice. But you know what? Harry did not raise her to marry a roughneck.
杰瑞·布鲁克海默让某个扮演飞行员的著名演员这么做过。我确信我们能弄清楚那是谁。我知道。好吧，听着，哈里并没有打扰这个奇怪的依偎环节，但他确实和他的所有手下汇合了。手下们说，听着，哈里，格蕾丝已经长大了。她也是个真正的辣妹，我们大家可以说都是看着她长大的，我们认为AJ是个很棒的选择。但你知道吗？哈里把她养大可不是为了让她嫁给一个粗人。
She's better than all of them. She deserves better than this. Yeah. By the way, this is now actually when they're going to go to the test site and test the armadillo underwater. And this is important because they've divided up into their two crews. And the armadillo, we should say, is this like special kind of. of vehicle where the wheels can rotate multiple directions. It's like an all-terrain vehicle that they're
她比他们所有人都好。她值得更好的。是的。顺便说一句，现在实际上是他们要去测试场在水下测试“犰狳”号的时候了。这很重要，因为他们分成了两个船员小组。而且我们应该说，“犰狳”号是一种特殊的车辆，它的车轮可以向多个方向旋转。它就像一辆全地形车，他们
going to be able to drive with the drill and the nuke on the face of the asteroid. Right. Exactly. And AJ is doing his test and they're like, pull back, pull back. And he's like, no, it can take it. And he blows up his drill simulation. And they have to get in another argument where AJ is like, why don't you trust my gut? Their simulation doesn't know what this drill can really do. The computer doesn't know what's real. Yeah. So they get in a whole fight about it.
将驾驶它携带钻头和核弹到小行星表面。对的。没错。AJ正在进行他的测试，其他人喊着，拉回来，拉回来。而他说，不，它承受得住。然后他把他的钻探模拟装置给炸了。他们不得不再次争论，AJ觉得，为什么你不相信我的直觉？他们的模拟器根本不知道这个钻头真正能做到什么。计算机不知道什么是真实的。是的。所以他们为此大吵了一架。
This leads to a conversation where, you know, Bruce Willis's character, Harry is like, maybe these guys have been working too hard. They need to blow off some steam. You know what? This might be their last night on Earth. So we find out this is the final day of their training. Yeah.
这引发了一场对话，你知道，布鲁斯·威利斯饰演的角色，哈里觉得，也许这些家伙工作太卖力了。他们需要放松一下。你知道吗？这可能是他们在地球上的最后一晚。所以我们发现这是他们训练的最后一天。是的。
They're blasting off tomorrow and they need a night out so that they can quote remember what they're fighting for. Yeah. This is what that montage is going to look like. Yeah. There's the famous animal cracker scene where Grace, played by Liv Tyler and AJ, they drive a convertible BMW to a shack by a swampy field who lives in the shack. What is this shack? There's some white lights in a tree, like twinkly lights.
他们明天就要起飞了，他们需要一个晚上的时间来“记住他们在为之战斗的是什么”。是的。这就是那个蒙太奇的样子。是的。有那个著名的动物饼干场景，由丽芙·泰勒饰演的格蕾丝和AJ开着一辆敞篷宝马来到沼泽地旁的一个小屋，谁住在那个小屋里？这是什么小屋？树上有一些白色的灯，就像一闪一闪的灯。
They don't go in the shack. They go outside of the shack with only a little. animal crackers. I saw no water. Those crackers make me so thirsty. Yeah, well, and then Ben Affleck has to have his clever dialogue where he says, are these really crackers? I mean, I think they're cookies because they're sweet and because you don't put cheese on them. Well, there was a lot of improv there. So some of that. Oh, boy. And then he does like sexy cracker going down her belly stuff. The song playing in the background, you know, we've talked about it, Aerosmith.
他们没有进小屋。他们走出了小屋，只带着一点动物饼干。我没看到水。那些饼干让我觉得好渴。是的，好吧，然后本·阿弗莱克不得不说出他那聪明的台词，他说，这些真的是饼干吗？我的意思是，我觉得它们是甜点，因为它们是甜的，而且你不会在上面放奶酪。好吧，那里有很多即兴发挥。所以其中一些。哦，天哪。然后他在她肚子上做那种性感的饼干碎屑下滑的事情。背景里播放的歌，你知道的，我们讨论过，史密斯飞船。
So basically, Liv Tyler's dad, Steve Tyler, is singing in the background of this scene. Yes. And then the other guys go do stuff.
所以基本上，丽芙·泰勒的爸爸，史蒂夫·泰勒，正在这个场景的背景中唱歌。是的。然后其他人去干别的事了。
No surprise. Steve Buschemy's character goes to a strip club. One of them goes to see their kid, but the kid doesn't know him. Well, first he goes and borrows a hundred grand from the mob. Oh, right.
毫不意外。史蒂夫·布西密的角色去了一家脱衣舞俱乐部。其中一个人去看他的孩子，但孩子不认识他。好吧，首先他去黑帮那里借了十万块钱。哦，对了。
Which I'm confused about, I'm sorry, there's this whole thing about, like, why did you become an oil driller if you're so smart? And he's like, the money's good. And I like going to different places. If the money's so good, why do you have to borrow money from the mob all the time?
我很困惑，抱歉，这里有个整体的问题，就像，你既然这么聪明，为什么还要当石油钻工？而他说，钱多啊。而且我喜欢去不同的地方。如果钱这么多，你为什么还要一直向黑帮借钱？
I don't know. Aren't these guys rich? I thought they were rich. I don't know. Well, listen, AJ lives in a shack by a swamp. Right. But he has a BMW convertible. Maybe they don't make good choices.
我不知道。这些家伙不是很富有吗？我以为他们很富有。我不知道。好吧，听着，AJ住在沼泽旁的小屋里。对的。但他有一辆宝马敞篷车。也许他们做不出好的选择。
Okay. Oh, well, the one guy you said, Angela, you started to say, chick, he is going to go visit his son who doesn't know who he is. But he's going to leave him a little shuttle toy. Yeah. Exactly. He's sorry that he hasn't been there for his son. And we're going to meet who I assume is his ex-wife or ex-girlfriend. We're not sure.
好吧，安吉，你刚才说的那个人，奇克，他要去探望他的儿子，而那个儿子根本不认识他。但他要留给儿子一个小的航天飞机玩具。是的。没错。他为自己没有陪伴儿子感到抱歉。然后我们要见到的我猜是他的前妻或前女友。我们不确定。
Right. She's another just like minor character played by a woman and she is annoyed. Yes. Then we have this scene back at NASA between Billy Bob and Bruce and I'm sorry I keep saying their names. I can't remember who's who. I can't remember. I couldn't remember anybody's name in this movie except for Steve Bouchemmy's character
对的。她只是另一个由女性扮演的小角色，而且她很恼火。是的。然后我们在NASA有了一场比利·鲍勃和布鲁斯的对手戏，抱歉我一直说他们的名字。我记不清谁是谁了。我记不住。在这部电影里，除了史蒂夫·布西密饰演的角色
whose name is Rockhound. I never knew his name, but I knew Harry and AJ and Grace. Okay, but anyway, we learn, okay, Michael Bay said that Billy Bob was like, I want to have something about me that's like revealed. So we find out he can't go to space because he has a leg like in a brace. Yeah, right? He always wished he could actually be an astronaut in space. Yes, so.
叫“寻岩者”之外，我谁的名字都记不住。我从来不知道他的名字，但我知道哈里、AJ和格蕾丝。好吧，不管怎样，我们了解到，迈克尔·贝说比利·鲍勃想要展现自己的一些特点。所以我们发现他不能去太空，因为他的腿上戴着支架。是的，对吧？他一直希望自己能真正成为太空中的宇航员。是的，所以。
He has a heart to heart with Bruce Willis. That's right. But also right now, guess what? Part of the asteroid hits Southeast Asia and 50,000 people are killed. And now the whole world knows about the asteroid. They can't keep it a secret anymore. People are panicked. Guess what, everyone?
他和布鲁斯·威利斯进行了一次心与心的交流。没错。但也就是现在，你猜怎么着？小行星的一部分击中了东南亚，5万人丧生。现在全世界都知道这颗小行星的事了。他们再也无法隐瞒了。人们陷入了恐慌。你猜怎么着，各位？
You are over 45 minutes into the movie and you haven't left for space yet. No, everyone get up and go pee because we have an hour and 30 minutes more. Maybe we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to finally launch this. Into space. We're going to launch into space. Back and during our break, Sam uncovered a delicious nugget to continue the conversation about Ben Affleck's teeth.
电影已经播放了45分钟多，你们还没出发去太空呢。不，大家都起来去上个厕所，因为我们还有一个半小时。也许我们应该休息一下。等我们回来，我们终于要发射这个东西了。去太空。我们要发射到太空去了。回去吧，在休息期间，萨姆挖掘出了一个绝妙的八卦，来继续关于本·阿弗莱克牙齿的话题。
Oh, gosh. Okay. Ben Affleck gave an interview about it, lady. And this is also going to focus on how important it was to Michael Bay that this movie be sexy. Here is what Ben Affleck said. Michael Bay made me fix my teeth and work out and be sexy. Be sexy, how do I do that? Go to the gym.
哦，天哪。好吧。本·阿弗莱克接受了一次关于这件事的采访，女士。这也将重点关注迈克尔·贝认为这部电影性感有多么重要。本·阿弗莱克是这么说的。迈克尔·贝让我整牙、健身并变得性感。变得性感，我该怎么做？去健身房。
Running in the gym and putting oil on my body and stuff, and it just turned out to be a long-form version of one of those male topless calendars in a garage, carrying a tire kind of greased up. According to Affleck, Michael Bay had a very specific vision for the movie that included, quote, a glistening male torso in oil, and he was like, that's going to go in the trailer and sell tickets.
在健身房跑步，在身上抹油之类的，结果这变成了一个长视频版本的车库里的那种半裸男性挂历，扛着一个轮胎，全身抹得油光发亮的。根据阿弗莱克的说法，迈克尔·贝对这部电影有一个非常具体的愿景，其中包括“抹了油的闪闪发光的男性躯干”，而他当时觉得，“这将会放进预告片里用来卖票”。
I'm telling you, I think the song that runs like rent-free in Michael Bay's head is, I'm bringing sexy back. What? I mean, for sure. All right, everybody, it is launch day. Don't worry, it's going to take so long before we're finally in the air because we have some more montages. Yeah.
我告诉你，我觉得迈克尔·贝脑子里挥之不去的歌肯定是《I'm bringing sexy back》（我把性感带回来了）。什么？我的意思是，肯定的。好吧，各位，今天是发射日。别担心，在终于飞上天之前还要花很长时间，因为我们还有更多的蒙太奇。是的。
First, Grace and Harry have a very serious. sweet scene where they apologize to one another. Grace is like, Dad, I'm sorry. He's like, honey, I'm sorry. And she's like, just promise me you're going to come back. Promise me. And he promises her. Yes. And she says, please bring my fiance home. Yes. He's like, you got it. You got it. We have a slow motion montage of everyone's suiting up. Then we have what I'm pretty sure is the cringiest moment of the whole movie that was really painful to watch. And it is Ben Affleck singing leaving on a jet plane to live Tyler. They talk about it in the DVD commentary.
首先，格蕾丝和哈里有一场非常严肃温馨的戏，他们互相道歉。格蕾丝说：“爸爸，对不起。”他说：“亲爱的，对不起。”她说：“只要答应我你会回来。答应我。”他向她保证。是的。她说：“请把我的未婚夫带回家。”是的。他说：“包在我身上。包在我身上。”接着是一段慢动作蒙太奇，每个人都在穿宇航服。然后是我们几乎可以确定是整部电影中最尴尬的时刻，看的时候真的很痛苦。那就是本·阿弗莱克为丽芙·泰勒演唱《乘喷气机离开》。他们在DVD评论音轨里谈到了这个。
Basically, they were like, this was either going to work or it was going to bomb. It bombed. Why did they include it? I think they thought it worked. Really? Michael Bay did say that they all sang different keys, and it was a little tough to edit.
基本上，他们的意思是，这要么行得通，要么彻底砸锅。结果砸了。他们为什么要把这个剪进去？我想他们觉得这行得通。真的吗？迈克尔·贝确实说过，他们每个人唱的调子都不一样，剪辑起来有点困难。
I thought the biggest cringe, though, wasn't the song. It was when his character picks up Grace, and then she tries to wrap her letters. around him but can't because he's in a space suit. Yeah. So awkward. Now we're going to have a president's speech and he says, the Bible calls this day Armageddon, the end of all things.
不过，我认为最尴尬的不是这首歌。而是当他的角色抱起格蕾丝时，她试图把双臂缠在他身上，但因为他穿着宇航服，根本做不到。是的。太尴尬了。现在我们要听总统演讲了，他说，圣经把这一天称为世界末日，万物的终结。
But, you know, we're going to fight. We're going to come together. Yeah. But this is the moment you hear the title of the movie. I'm always kind of a geek for that. Yeah. Like I think it's cool if you're the character that gets to say the title of the movie. Yeah.
但是，你知道，我们要战斗。我们要团结起来。是的。但这就是你听到电影名字的时刻。我总是对这种事有点着迷。是的。就像我觉得如果你是那个有机会说出电影名字的角色，那真的很酷。是的。
And there's a montage, big montage people all over the world are listening to this. What year is it in this montage? Why does America look like it's 1934? Why is everyone listening to the president's speech on the radio? There's children in dresses. There's a boy in overalls and no shirt. Nobody has shoes on. I mean, I was waiting for like that little kid to be like,
然后是一个蒙太奇，一个世界各地的人们都在听这个的大型蒙太奇。这个蒙太奇里到底是哪一年？为什么美国看起来像是1934年？为什么每个人都在用收音机听总统演讲？有穿着连衣裙的孩子。有一个穿着背带裤、光着上司的男孩。谁都没穿鞋。我的意思是，我一直在等那个小男孩说：
Paul, Paul, come. It's so weird. It's so weird. Also, as they're suiting up, did you notice everybody, their spacesuit has their name. Bruce Willis says Harry. And the name they put on Steve Ushammy's space suit is Rockhound. They put his nickname.
“保罗，保罗，过来。”太诡异了。太诡异了。还有，当他们穿宇航服的时候，你注意到每个人的宇航服上都有他们的名字吗？布鲁斯·威利斯写的是哈里。他们印在史蒂夫·布西密宇航服上的名字是“猎犬”。他们印的是他的外号。
They put Rockhound on his official space suit. I mean, that's what. Not his name. You know what? I mean, when you're bringing sexy back to NASA, this is what you do. I guess so. Well, it is blast off time. Chef's Kiss, I thought this was beautifully done.
他们把“猎犬”印在了他的官方宇航服上。我的意思是，那是……而不是他的名字。你知道吗？我的意思是，当你要把性感带回NASA时，你就会这么做。我想是的。好吧，现在是发射时间。主厨之吻，我觉得这拍得太美了。
Michael Bay shared that he found out a month after They filmed the daytime scenes of them walking out onto the ramp and all the things, right? Which NASA gave them permission to film there. Oh, my God. That a month later, there was going to be a night launch. He was really excited about that because it lights up so much better and looks more vibrant on the screen. So he was able to go back, I guess, and get some of that night launch. Footage?
迈克尔·贝分享说，他是在他们拍摄他们走到坡道上等白天场景的一个月后才发现的，对吧？当时美国宇航局允许他们在那里拍摄。哦，天哪。一个月后，将有一场夜间发射。他对这一点非常兴奋，因为这样灯光效果好得多，在银幕上看起来也更有活力。所以我想他能够回去，拍到一些夜间发射的镜头。
For the launch. I had a question, can you launch two space shuttles side by side at the same time? Is that safe? I'm going to say no because of how much it kicks up when it takes off. I feel like it would send the other one like spinning out. You're correct. It is not safe. Real shuttles could not launch side by side due to, quote, catastrophic acoustic and debris risks.
关于发射。我有个问题，你可以同时把两个航天器并排放置发射吗？这安全吗？我要说不安全，因为起飞时会掀起巨大的气浪。我觉得这会把另一个震得旋转起来。你说得对。这并不安全。真正的航天器由于所谓的“灾难性声学和碎片风险”，无法并排发射。
Well, there you go. But I was able to put this mission into eight steps. And I'm excited to talk about each step. Step one is blast off and it goes great. Here's the thing about the rest of the movie. It's going to shift pretty much every two minutes between hope or destruction. We're never going to live in one of these two places for very long. It really is intense.
好吧，就是这样。但我能够把这次任务分为八个步骤。我很高兴讨论每一个步骤。第一步是发射，一切进展顺利。关于这部电影的剩余部分，情况是这样的：它将在希望和毁灭之间每两分钟转变一次。我们永远不会在这两种状态中停留太久。这真的很紧张。
Well, here's the thing, guys. The first thing they have to do is they have to dock onto a Russian space station. This is step two. They have to refuel. They have to refuel. Michael Bay said that they actually talked to the astronauts on the mirror space station. And he said they call it, quote, the glove box of an old car. Because everything gets lost in there.
好吧，情况是这样的，伙计们。他们要做的第一件事就是与俄罗斯空间站对接。这是第二步。他们必须加油。他们必须加油。迈克尔·贝说，他们实际上和“和平号”空间站的宇航员交谈过。他说他们把它称为，引述一下，“旧汽车的杂物箱”。因为所有东西都会掉在里面丢掉。
I guess it smells like leaky sewage and there's mold. And he said the people up there that have to live there do get a little loopy. Well, the Russian who is there, he seems like he's alone and he's Krez. He's a little Kray. He insists that Ben Affleck go down into this, I don't know, tube and watch the pressure gauge for the fuel. And if it gets to this certain number, it's bad and he's got to hit this button. And then he has to pull this lever, which, guess what? Four seconds into refueling, the pressure gauge goes past 200 and everything starts sparking.
我猜它闻起来像泄漏的污水，而且有霉菌。他说上面那些必须住在那里的人确实有点精神失常。好吧，那个在那里的俄罗斯人，他看起来像是孤身一人，而且他疯了。他有点精神错乱。他坚持让本·阿弗莱克走到这个，我不知道，管道里，盯着燃料的压力表。如果压力达到某个特定的数字，那就是坏事，他就得按下这个按钮。然后他必须拉动这个杠杆，猜怎么着？加油四秒钟后，压力表就超过了200，所有东西都开始冒火花。
Well, Ben Affleck breaks the lever. point out, our quote, heroes have been on this Russian space station for not a minute and they blow it up. Like, truly, like the entire station starts sparking and catching fire. But luckily, they all get back to their respective shuttles and they blast away from the space station with like seconds to spare before the whole thing explodes. There is no more space station. No, that's it. It's a goner. Luckily, they let us know they got 90% of the fuel they needed. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Yeah, not all of it, but enough. I guess.
好吧，本·阿弗莱克把杠杆弄断了。我要指出的是，我们的“英雄”们在这个俄罗斯空间站上呆了不到一分钟就把这里炸毁了。真的，就像整个空间站开始冒火花并着火一样。但幸运的是，他们都回到了各自的航天器上，并在整个空间站爆炸前的几秒钟内飞离了空间站。空间站不复存在了。不，就是这样。它完蛋了。幸运的是，他们让我们知道他们得到了所需燃料的90%。是的。嗯哼。是的，虽然不是全部，但足够了。我想是的。
I guess. I want to say that in my estimation, I really felt like step two seemed like the easiest step after blast off. Should I go through the steps? Step one was blast off. Step two is refuel at the Russian space station. Step three is enter lunar orbit and slingshot around the moon. At nine Gs. Step four is land on the asteroid.
我想是的。我想说的是，据我估计，我真的觉得第二步似乎是发射之后最简单的一步。我要把这些步骤过一遍吗？第一步是发射。第二步是在俄罗斯空间站加油。第三步是进入月球轨道并绕月球做弹弓飞跃。在9个G的重力下。第四步是降落到小行星上。
Step five is drilled the whole. step six is put the nuclear bomb inside. Step seven is fly away from the asteroid. And step eight is blow up the asteroid. So we're at step two, which was refuel, and it's already a fucking shit show. So now we're going into step three, which is slingshot around the moon.
第五步是钻孔。第六步是把核弹放进去。第七步是飞离小行星。第八步是炸毁小行星。所以我们现在在第二步，也就是加油，这已经是一团糟了。现在我们要进入第三步，绕月球做弹弓飞跃。
Yeah. This is the only step that goes well besides blast off. I did look up if you can survive at 9Gs. Uh-huh. I guess you can, but only for a few minutes. They are going to be at 9 G's for 11 minutes. One of the astronauts says, this is what we train for, suck it up. Yeah.
是的。这是除了发射之外唯一顺利的一步。我确实查过你是否能在9个G的重力下存活。嗯哼。我想你可以，但只能坚持几分钟。他们将在9个G的重力下坚持11分钟。其中一名宇航员说：“这就是我们训练的目的，挺过去。”是的。
For Michael Bay, they shot this on a huge gimbal. It was an advanced hydraulic platform that was shaking the actors, in his words, quote, quite violently, forwards, backwards, sideways. It was also similar to being in a car accident. Wow. Yeah. I mean, they didn't look well. I know. During this scene.
对于迈克尔·贝来说，他们是在一个巨大的万向支架上拍摄的。这是一个先进的液压平台，用他的话说，会“相当猛烈地”前后左右摇晃演员。这也类似于遭遇车祸。哇。是的。我的意思是，他们看起来状态不好。我知道。在这场戏期间。
I thought they looked like they were being shaken quite violently. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, lady, I think about how sometimes on the office we would do a scene and they would be like, Angela Martin whips her head and gives Kelly a mean look. And I would have to like eight takes in a row whip my head and give Kelly a mean look. and I'd whip my head back, and I'd be sore. Yeah.
我觉得他们看起来像是被相当猛烈地摇晃着。是的。是的。我的意思是，女士，我想起有时我们在《办公室》里拍一场戏，他们会说：“安吉拉·马丁猛地甩头，给凯莉一个刻薄的眼神。”我不得不连续拍八条，每次都猛地甩头，给凯莉一个刻薄的眼神。然后我把头甩回来，结果脖子都酸了。是的。
How do you feel after you're in a gimbal being shaken quite violently? I don't know. I don't know. But you have new teeth, so. I guess you have that. You've got that. Step four, we're at step four now. They need to land on the asteroid.
你在一个被相当猛烈摇晃的万向支架里呆过之后感觉怎么样？我不知道。我不知道。但你换了新牙，所以。我想你还有这个。你还有这个。第四步，我们现在到第四步了。他们需要降落到小行星上。
Here is what I wrote. How? Literally how. Because little asteroids are kind of falling off the big asteroid. They're flying through space. You're like flying through space. You're like flying through. all of this debris to land on a moving object that's all jaggedy.
这是我写的内容。怎么降落？字面意义上的怎么降落。因为小块的小行星正从大块小行星上剥落下来。它们在太空中飞驰。你就像在太空中飞翔。你就像在飞过所有这些碎片，去降落在一个移动的、满是锯齿的物体上。
I wondered, can space shuttles really fly like this? Because they're flying these two space shuttles like they're the Millennium Falcon. Guess what? The answer is no. Real space shuttles are gliders. They cannot take off or maneuver around an asteroid. They don't fly like that. But that's why we learned early in the movie that these are special.
我在想，航天器真的能这样飞行吗？因为他们驾驶这两个航天器的样子就像它们是千年隼号。你猜怎么着？答案是不能。真正的航天器是滑翔机。它们无法在小行星周围起飞或机动。它们不是那样飞行的。但这也就是为什么我们在电影早期了解到这些是特殊的。
They've got special reimbled. Forcements and they can fly like all this shit. Yeah. But guess what happens as they're trying to land on the asteroid? Well, they lose the independence aircraft. That one's a goner. Can I just say something? Immediately at the beginning of this movie when they told me that they were going to be dividing into two shuttles.
它们有特殊的改装加固，它们可以像这样飞来飞去。是的。但你猜当他们试图降落到小行星上时发生了什么？好吧，他们失去了“独立号”飞船。那个彻底完蛋了。我能说句话吗？在这部电影一开始，当他们告诉我他们要分成两艘航天器时。
Yeah. You know. I'm thinking to myself, dear God, let me be on the one. With Bruce Willis? Yeah. Because we know the other one is going down. But AJ's on the other one. Ben Affleck's on the other one.
是的。你知道的。我在心里想，天哪，让我呆在布鲁斯·威利斯那艘上吧。是的。因为我们知道另一艘要坠毁。但AJ在另一艘上。本·阿弗莱克在另一艘上。
He is, and it goes down. Mm-hmm. One of my favorite moments is that as the asteroid hits the independence, we cut back to NASA, and you see Billy Bob Thornton's coffee mug drop, and it hits the side of the table and it breaks. Oh, I miss that. So there's tragedy all around, okay? Even back at NASA, things are breaking. Oh, my gosh.
他是，而且它坠毁了。嗯哼。我最喜欢的时刻之一是，当小行星撞击“独立号”时，镜头切回美国纳斯达克指挥中心，你看到比利·鲍勃·松顿的咖啡杯掉落，砸在桌子边缘摔碎了。哦，我漏掉了这个。所以到处都是悲剧，好吧？连NASA总部的东西都在碎。哦，天哪。
I'm surprised it doesn't burst into flames. Exactly. Like that it didn't like spill onto the control center. Yeah. Same. All right, I want you to know what I wrote down during this scene. Here's what I wrote. How did they imagine it was ever possible to land on this asteroid?
我很惊讶它没有突然着火。没错。就像它没有溅到控制中心一样。是的。我也是。好吧，我想让你知道我在这一幕中记下了什么。这是我写的：他们怎么会觉得在小行星上着陆是可能的？
Oh my God, they're hit again. Now astronauts are being sucked out of the windows. But wait, are some of them escaping? Oh, shit. I think Owen Wilson just died. Bruce Willis' ship is now getting hit with debris from the other shuttles. and Bruce Willis says, quote, what is that? Is that the independence?
哦，天哪，他们又挨撞了。现在宇航员被吸出了窗外。但是等等，有人逃生了吗？哦，操。我想欧文·威尔逊刚刚死了。布鲁斯·威利斯的飞船现在正被其他航天器上的碎片击中，布鲁斯·威利斯说：“那是什么？那是独立号吗？”
And right after that, an astronaut is hurled into his window. Mm-hmm. Yeah. So, yes, the independence has crashed onto the surface of the asteroid, but I think Ben Affleck is still alive. Well, we find out. We find out that Ben Affleck, so A.J., Bear, and the Russian, they made it somehow.
就在那之后，一名宇航员被撞向他的窗户。嗯哼。所以，是的，“独立号”已经坠毁在小行星表面，但我认为本·阿弗莱克还活着。好吧，我们发现了。我们发现本·阿弗莱克，也就是AJ、贝尔和俄罗斯人，不知怎的活了下来。
But back at Houston, it's assumed they're all dead. Yes. Nobody knows this. There's some montages back in Houston of like worried, sad people. Yeah. But now Bruce Wallace's team, they get out that big buggy thing, you know, the armadillo. They land. They land.
但在休斯敦，大家以为他们都死了。是的。没有人知道这一点。休斯敦那边有一些忧心忡忡、面露悲伤的人们的蒙太奇。是的。但现在布鲁斯·威利斯的团队拿出了那个巨大的越野车，你知道的，犰狳号。他们着陆了。他们着陆了。
But they overshot their landing field, lady. Oh. They overshot it. I was like, there's a landing field. By 26 miles. I mean, my God. They didn't even know what the asteroid looked like up close. How do they know there's a landing field?
但他们的着陆点偏了，女士。哦。他们偏离了着陆场。当时我想，居然还有着陆场。偏离了26英里。我的天。他们甚至不知道小行星近距离长什么样。他们怎么知道那里有个着陆场？
I don't know. But also now their communication system is. not going well. Yeah, and they've also landed on mostly iron rock, which as we all know at this point is horrible to drill in iron rock. Can't drill through it. Yeah. So now we're going to start on step five, which is drilling the hole and they have eight hours. Eight hours, they have to get 800 feet.
我不知道。而且现在他们的通信系统也出了问题。是的，而且他们降落的大多是铁岩石，正如我们现在都知道的那样，在铁岩石上钻孔简直糟透了。根本钻不穿。是的。所以现在我们要开始第五步，也就是钻孔，他们有八个小时。八个小时，他们必须钻800英尺。
Guess what? They break their first drill bit in 10 feet. Mm-hmm. They do. Here was another question that I had, which was, how are they walking on the asteroid? How is this rover thing staying stuck to the surface of the asteroid? Why is it not floating away? Why is there gravity on the asteroid?
你猜怎么着？他们在10英尺处就弄断了第一个钻头。嗯哼。确实如此。我还有另一个问题，那就是：他们是怎么在小行星上行走的？这个月球车是怎么紧贴在小行星表面的？为什么它没有漂走？为什么小行星上有重力？
I looked it up. There would not be gravity on the asteroid. Again, early in the movie, we have this little moment where they explain that their suits. Remember when they're not paying attention to the woman? She's explaining that their suits have special little thrusters that will keep them stuck to the asteroid. But no one is using the thrusters. No one's using them. You never see evidence of these thrusters.
我查过了。小行星上本来不应该有重力。同样，在电影早期，我们有这样一个短暂的桥段，他们解释说他们的宇航服……还记得当他们没有注意到那个女的的时候吗？她解释说他们的宇航服有特殊的微型推进器，可以让它们紧贴在小行星上。但没有人使用推进器。没有人使用它们。你从未看到这些推进器的痕迹。
Yeah. It's very strange. Neil deGrasse Tyson said that until the release of the 2022 film Moonfall, Armageddon was the movie which violated more laws of physics per minute than any other movie ever. And NASA shows this film during their management training program. And new managers are given the task of trying to spot as many errors as possible. So far, they've spotted at least 160. So NASA uses this movie the way human resources uses an episode of the office of how not to behave at the office.
是的。这太奇怪了。尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森曾说过，在2022年电影《月球坠落》上映之前，《地球末日》是每分钟违反物理定律最多的电影。美国国家航空航天局（NASA）在他们的管理培训项目播放这部电影，新经理们被委派的任务是尽量找出尽可能多的错误。到目前为止，他们已经发现了至少160个。所以NASA使用这部电影的方式，就像人力资源部门使用《办公室》里的一集来教导员工如何在办公室里不该怎么做一样。
Yes. And this is, can you tell me everything that's wrong from a scientific point of view? And one of the things is that there would not be gravity on this asteroid. Right. I guess there was a moment where they had to kind of pretend like they were spacewalking. then Michael Bay was like really perturbed at Ben Affleck because he was like, didn't you learn this in acting school? Because I guess he was really bad at it and faking it. And he was like, no, Michael Bay. I didn't learn like floating clown walking.
是的。从科学的角度来看，你能告诉我所有不对的地方吗？其中一点就是这个小行星上本不该有重力。对的。我猜有一个镜头，他们不得不假装在太空行走，然后迈克尔·贝对本·阿弗莱克真的很恼火，因为他说：“你没在表演学校里学过这个吗？”因为我猜他演得真的很差，装得很假。本·阿弗莱克说：“没有，迈克尔·贝。我没学过什么漂浮小丑走路。”
Like, you know. Anyway, oh my gosh. Wow. All right. So now the three remaining members of the independents, they're going to get into their armadillo. They're going to shoot through the wall of their shuttle. they're going to bust out.
就像，你知道的。不管怎样，哦，天哪。哇。好吧。所以现在“独立号”剩下的三名成员要上他们的犰狳号了。他们要冲破航天器的舱壁。他们要冲出来。
Shoot through their wall. Ben. AJ has like, I don't know, like a Gatlin gun. Yeah. Why did they bring this? I don't know. And he just goes, rat da-ta-ta-da-rat-da-rat-ta-da.
冲破舱壁。本。AJ手里拿着一个，我不知道，就像加特林机枪。是的。他们为什么要带这个？我不知道。然后他就开始“哒哒哒哒哒哒哒”。
And he just blows a hole through the side of the shuttle. Now they're driving onto the asteroid. Where do they think they're going? They've decided to try to find the freedom. Oh, he's got a tracker. He said he has a tracker. He's, oh, I missed that. That's like tracking him to the freedom.
他直接在飞船侧面轰出一个洞。现在他们正开着车上小行星。他们觉得自己要去哪？他们决定试着找到自由号。哦，他有个追踪器。他说他有个追踪器。他，哦，我漏掉了。就像用追踪器找到自由号一样。
They can't talk to Houston, but his tracker works. Yeah, and freedom doesn't know. I guess they're not looking at their tracker. Yeah, they don't know. So now they're on the way. You guys, at the same time, lunar gravity is making the asteroid start to spin, and Houston is not going to have any communication with them. Yeah, the asteroid is going to hit the Earth in now about six and a half hours,
他们无法与休斯敦通话，但他的追踪器管用。是的，而自由号那边不知道。我猜他们没在看他们的追踪器。是的，他们不知道。所以现在他们在路上。伙计们，与此同时，月球重力正使小行星开始旋转，休斯敦将无法与他们取得任何联系。是的，小行星将在大约六个半小时后撞击地球，
but they're going to lose contact with them in the next seven minutes. Uh-huh. If they lose the ability to communicate, they lose the ability to remotely detonate the nuclear bomb. And this is going to send us into, ready? What? For my dramatic delivery? What? Secondary protocol.
但他们将在接下来的七分钟内失去与他们的联系。嗯哼。如果他们失去了通信能力，他们就失去了远程引爆核弹的能力。这将把我们带入，准备好了吗？什么？听我的戏剧性台词？什么？二级预案。
Yes. Harry and the pilot of the freedom are arguing. The pilot wants an update. You've been drilling for two and a half hours. You're supposed to be reaching 800 feet. You should be 200 feet by now. How far are you? like my current depth is 57 feet. They're not going to get it done in time. Yeah. So the president has to
是的。哈里和自由号的飞行员在争吵。飞行员想要最新进展。你们已经钻了两个半小时了。你们本该达到800英尺。现在应该到200英尺了。你们到哪了？像我目前的深度是57英尺。他们无法按时完成。是的。所以总统不得不
decide, do you want to remote detonate the bomb in the next five minutes? It doesn't matter they haven't drilled a hole. I don't think the hole is going to happen. Should you just blow them all up on this asteroid and hope that it does something to the asteroid? So Angela Kinsey, survival guide tip. What is it? If they send you out there, they're going to have plans to blow it up no matter what. This is a one-way mission, okay? Don't get on the shuttle. Well, one of my favorite things about this is that no sooner does the military guy on the phone with the president hang up, the president says, do it, blow it up. Yeah. No sooner does he hang up the elevator door dings and 50 military men walk into the Houston Command Center. Yeah, their secondary protocol. They're taken
决定，你想在接下来的五分钟内远程引爆核弹吗？他们还没钻好洞也无所谓了。我觉得那个洞是钻不成了。你应该直接把他们连同小行星一起炸上天，希望这能对小行星起作用吗？所以，安吉拉·金西的求生指南小贴士。是什么？如果他们把你派到那里去，他们就会有无论如何都要炸毁它的计划。这是一次有去无回的任务，好吗？别上那个航天器。好吧，我最喜欢这其中的一点是，电话里跟总统通完话的军事人员刚一挂断电话，总统就说：“做吧，把它炸了。”是的。他刚一挂电话，电梯门“叮”的一声响了，50名军人走进了休斯敦指挥中心。是的，他们的二级预案。他们接管了
over. Where were they? Were they in the lobby waiting? Where they is like these guys got there so fast to take over. Yeah. And meanwhile, Billy Bob's character is being sneaky and he grabs one of the NASA dudes, one of the very unsexy NASA guys. And he says, kill the uplink. Yeah. Kill the uplink. The military guys take over and they turn on the bomb. It's ticking down. Yeah. And so now you see this guy. He's flipping through a binder. He's reading some code. He's punching stuff in, the sneaky sneaky punching in. Exactly. Through this whole bomb ticking thing, the pilot and Harry, and I started calling him Dad Guy, the guy with the kid back on Earth. Yes. Okay. They're all fighting. Yeah.
这里。他们在哪？他们在前厅等着吗？哪有这种事，这群人接管的速度也太快了。是的。与此同时，比利·鲍勃的角色鬼鬼祟祟地抓住了一个NASA的员工，一个非常不性感的NASA员工。他说：“切断上行链路。”是的。切断上行链路。军方人员接管了控制权，并启动了炸弹。倒计时正在进行。是的。所以现在你看到这家伙在翻阅一个文件夹。他在读一些代码，他在输入东西，鬼鬼祟祟地输入。没错。在整个炸弹倒计时过程中，飞行员和哈里——我开始叫他爸爸男，那个在地球上有个孩子的家伙。是的。好吧。他们都在吵架。是的。
Harry grabs a giant wrench, like a wrench, but like the size of an arm. The pilot pulls out a gun. Harry says you're going to have to shoot me or turn off this bomb. Harry's got his giant wrench. The pilot has the bomb. It's a total standoff. And suddenly, the bomb stops ticking because Billy Bob Thornton's unsexy NASA guy turned it off. He stopped the uplink. So Harry takes this opportunity to hit the pilot with the giant wrench. And then he puts the wrench around the pilot's neck. Dad guy grabs the gun. That's a big wrench.
哈里抓起一把巨大的扳手，就像扳手，但有手臂那么大。飞行员拔出一枪。哈里说你得开枪打死我或者关掉这个炸弹。哈里拿着他的巨型扳手。飞行员拿着炸弹。这完全是一场对峙。突然，炸弹停止倒计时了，因为比利·鲍勃·松顿那个不性感的NASA员工把它关掉了。他切断了上行链路。于是哈里抓住这个机会用巨型扳手打了飞行员。然后他把扳手套在飞行员的脖子上。爸爸男抢走了枪。那是个大扳手。
It's so big. And here's the thing. Billy Bob Thornton only bought them a few minutes because while they're still arguing, the bomb starts ticking again. And Harry begs the pilot to turn off the bomb. He's like, you need to trust me. Here's the audio clip.
太大了。问题是，比利·鲍勃·松顿只为他们争取了几分钟时间，因为在他们还在争吵的时候，炸弹又开始倒计时了。哈里恳求飞行员关掉炸弹。他说：“你得相信我。”这是音频片段。
For God's sakes, think about what you're doing. Why are you listening to someone that's 100,000 miles away? We are here. Nobody down there can help us. If we don't get this job done, everybody's gone. One minute. I've been drilling holes in the earth for 30 years. And I have never, never missed the depth that I have aimed for.
看在上帝的份上，想想你在做什么。你为什么要听一个远在十万英里外的人的话？我们在这里。下面没有人能帮我们。如果我们不把这工作做完，所有人就都完了。还剩一分钟。我在地球上钻了30年孔。我从来没有，从来没有错过我瞄准的深度。
And by God, I am not going to miss this when I will make 800 feet. 42 seconds. But I can't do it alone, Colonel, I need your help. You swear on your daughter's life on my families that you can hit that mark. I will make 800 feet. I swear to God, I will. And let's turn this palm off. Yeah, that's the big speech.
凭着上帝的名义，我不会错过这次的，我会达到800英尺。还剩42秒。但我不能独自完成，上校，我需要你的帮助。你以你女儿的生命，以我家人的名义发誓你能达到那个目标。我会达到800英尺。我对上帝发誓，我会的。现在把这个炸弹关掉。是的，这就是那段精彩的演讲。
It has one of my favorite lines in it, you know, when he's like, I have never, never missed a depth that I have aimed for. And by God, I'm not going to miss this one. I mean, so good. And then, you guys, this starts a whole super. super stressful de-programming of the bomb. It's like, do I cut the red wire or the blue wire? I know. Red or blue.
里面有我最喜欢的台词之一，你知道的，当他说：“我从来没有，从来没有错过我瞄准的深度。凭着上帝的名义，我不会错过这次的。”我的意思是，太棒了。然后，伙计们，这就开始了整个超级超级紧张的拆弹程序。就像，我是该剪断红线还是蓝线？我知道。红的还是蓝的。
Red or blue. And then, thank God, they cut the right one. It was blue. It was blue. They stopped the bomb with two minutes and 46 seconds left to spare. Yeah. And they get enough radio reception for Bruce Willis to tell Houston that basically go f*** themselves.
红的还是蓝的。然后，谢天谢地，他们剪对了。是蓝色的。是蓝色的。他们在还剩两分四十六秒的时候阻止了炸弹。是的。他们得到了足够的无线电信号，让布鲁斯·威利斯告诉休斯敦让他们滚蛋。
They've got a hole to drill. Oh, he's got a classic. He says, now I don't know what you people are doing down there, but we got a hole to dig up here. Yeah. I know this is probably not the takeaway they were hoping for in this moment, but it's very ironic to me because what I wrote in my document is Bruce Willis has kind of crooked teeth. Yeah. But they're very white. But clearly, maybe they just made Bruce Willis white in his teeth, but he didn't get veneers for this. He didn't. He only has one that bucks out a little. I think Ben Affleck had like ferret teeth or something. You know what I'm saying? I mean, I mean, no shade.
他们还有一个洞要钻。哦，他说了一句经典台词。他说：“现在我不知道你们这群人在下面干什么，但我们在上面有个洞要挖。”是的。我知道这可能不是他们希望在这个时刻得到的感悟，但对我来说这非常讽刺，因为我在文档里写的是：布鲁斯·威利斯的牙齿有点歪。是的。但它们非常白。但显然，可能他们只是把布鲁斯·威利斯的牙齿P白了，但他并没有为此去做瓷贴面。他没有。他只有一颗牙有点突出。我觉得本·阿弗莱克长得像雪貂的牙齿什么的。你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，没有恶意。
My teeth are crooked on the bottom. I mean, I'm never going to be in a Michael Bay movies. I don't have to worry about it. Well, Ben Affleck was also the male lead. Yes. I also did write in my document as we watch Ben Affleck and the Russian and bears slowly make their way in this armadillo. They are so hot.
我的牙齿底部也是歪的。我的意思是，我永远不会去演迈克尔·贝的电影。我不用担心这个。好吧，本·阿弗莱克也是男主角。是的。我在文档里也写了，当我们看着本·阿弗莱克、俄罗斯人和贝尔慢慢挤进这个犰狳号时。他们太热了。
They are sweaty, sweaty, sweaty. So slathered them up. And oiled up. Lathered them up. So they really did oil him up. Yeah, he talks about it in the commentary. I just need to say, too, you know, because there's still a lot of movie left, to fast track this, AJ the bear in the Russian, they come up on a giant like Grand Canyon.
他们满身大汗，大汗淋漓。全身抹满了油。抹了油。全身涂满了油。所以他们确实给他抹了油。是的，他在评论音轨里谈到了这个。我只需要说，因为电影还有很多，为了快进剧情，AJ、贝尔和俄罗斯人来到了一个巨大的像大峡谷一样的地方。
Yeah. But you know what? They have a fuel thruster and they're going to jump it, guys. Yeah. They're going to, you know, freaking jump the canyon. Using anti-gravity. They're going to thrust up. Yeah.
是的。但你知道吗？他们有一个燃料推进器，他们打算飞跃过去，伙计们。是的。他们要，你知道的，去他妈的飞跃峡谷。利用反重力。他们要向上喷射推进。是的。
And then float over the canyon. Yeah. But then somehow gravity comes back. And, you know, things go sideways. Not surprising. And then the Russian guy goes outside and he's like trying to fix the fuel thing. Now he's just hanging on to the back of it as they're like hurtling through the canyon. Yes, by like a rope.
然后飘过峡谷。是的。但不知怎么的，重力又回来了。而且，你知道的，事情开始出岔子了。毫不奇怪。然后俄罗斯人走到外面，他试图修理燃料问题。现在他只是挂在车屁股后面，而车正飞驰着穿过峡谷。是的，靠一根绳子。
Yeah. The whole thing is literally spiraling. It's running into all kinds of debris. But guess what? They land on the other side of the canyon and the Russian is alive. Yeah. They make it. All of this is going on while Steve Bouchemmy's character finds the Gatlin gun on his armadillo,
是的。整个过程简直在呈螺旋式上升。它撞上了各种各样的碎片。但你猜怎么着？他们降落在了峡谷的另一边，俄罗斯人还活着。是的。他们成功了。所有这一切发生的同时，史蒂夫·布西明的角色找到了犰狳号上的加特林机枪，
starts firing it, and I guess they find out he has space dementia. Yes, I did a mini deep dive on. This was the part that I needed to pause the movie. I wrote down space dementia question mark and then Google, okay. So it's a hypothetical, it's a movie trope based on a real thing NASA was concerned about in the 1950s called space madness. So in the 1950s, medical experts feared space could cause severe psychological damage, impulsive behavior, or hallucinations. But they found in reality, space missions showed that the human minds will adapt well to orbit, leaving space madness as a trope for most Hollywood and science fiction movies. And this movie was the second time, the first time it was ever referenced, was in a 1991 episode of Renan Stumpy.
开始开火，我猜他们发现他得了太空痴呆症。是的，我对这个进行了微型深度挖掘。这就是我需要暂停电影的部分。我写下了“太空痴呆症问号”，然后谷歌了一下，好吧。所以这是一个假设，是一个基于NASA在20世纪50年代关心的真实事情的电影老套路，叫做太空疯狂。所以在20世纪50年代，医学专家担心太空会导致严重的心理损害、冲动行为或幻觉。但他们发现现实中，太空任务表明人类的心智可以很好地适应轨道，这让太空疯狂成为了大多数好莱坞和科幻电影的一个老套路。这部电影是第二次，也是第一次被提及是在1991年的一集《莱恩和史丁比》中。
Oh, okay. Yeah. All right. Well, he's gone mad and he's shooting this gun. That's not the only problem, though. No. Now the ground is cracking. Things are exploding.
哦，好吧。好吧。总之，他疯了，他在开枪。但这还不是唯一的问题，还有。没有。现在地面正在开裂。东西在爆炸。
Oh, yeah, like these horrible gases are coming up. And they lose Macs, the guy that was getting the tattoo earlier. Yeah. And their whole armadillo rig. Yeah. So now that's it. They can't drill anymore. Everyone is so dejected.
哦，是的，就像这些可怕的气体正在涌上来。他们失去了麦克斯，那个之前去纹身的人。是的。还有他们的整个犰狳号装备。是的。所以现在就这样了。他们不能再钻了。每个人都感到十分沮丧。
They're so sad. They can't complete the mission. Yeah. Back on Earth, they announced to everyone that the drilling was unsuccessful. They make an announcement to the world. Yeah. Why are they telling people? I don't know, but in slow motion, everyone starts preparing for the end of life as we know it.
他们太难过了。他们无法完成任务。是的。地球上，他们向所有人宣布钻探不成功。他们向全世界发布了公告。是的。他们为什么要告诉人们？我不知道，但是在慢动作中，每个人都开始为我们所知的生命终结做准备。
Yeah. Meanwhile, part of the asteroid hits Paris and now most of Paris is gone too. Yeah. So then they're like, should we evacuate these guys who are left? Get them up. To go where? Where are they evacuated to? Exactly.
是的。与此同时，小行星的一部分击中了巴黎，现在大部分巴黎也没了。是的。所以他们就在想：我们应该把剩下的这几个人撤离吗？把他们接上来。去哪？他们被撤离到哪里去？Exactly。
To live in space for a little bit longer, Earth is going to cease to exist in one hour. Yeah. But Liv Tyler is like super pissed. She's screaming at Billy Bob Thornton. Why won't you let them evacuate? To where, Liv Tyler? I know. She's got some space dementia too.
在太空中多活一会儿，地球一小时后将不复存在。是的。但丽芙·泰勒超级生气。她冲着比利·鲍勃·松顿尖叫。你为什么不让他们撤离？去哪儿，丽芙·泰勒？我知道。她也得了点太空痴呆症。
I guess so, you guys, I can't believe it. I cried three times in this movie. Were you on a plane? No. Did you have altitude thing? No. No, I often do cry on movies. Me too.
我想是的，伙计们，我真不敢相信。我在这部电影里哭了三次。你在飞机上吗？没有。你有高原反应吗？没有。没有，我经常看电影时哭。我也是。
That's why I said because I cry when I watch movies on the plane. Yeah. Here's the moment. These guys. They're stuck on this asteroid. It's hurtling toward Earth. They've lost their armadillo. And up on this, like, range, you see the lights from Ben Affleck's armadillo.
这就是为什么我说，因为我在飞机上看电影时会哭。是的。这就是那个时刻。这些人。他们被困在这颗小行星上。它正朝地球飞驰而来。他们失去了犰狳号。在这座山脉上，你看到了本·阿弗莱克的犰狳号的灯光。
You cried? Lady, you cried at that? And I legit cried. I was like, what is happening? And this is when I wrote, this movie swings between hope and tragedy every two minutes. I've never seen anything like it. What's happening to? Oh, that's so great.
你哭了？女士，你为那个哭了？我真的哭了。当时我在想，这到底是怎么回事？这就是我写下这段话的时候：这部电影每两分钟就在希望和悲剧之间摇摆。我从来没见过这样的东西。发生什么了？哦，太棒了。
Then I wrote, they tell Houston that we can start drilling again. Why don't they tell everyone on Earth that there's still hope? They don't tell anyone on Earth. I don't know. They didn't let anyone know. They didn't let anyone know. I do have a really great clip from Ben Affleck talking about working with Bruce Willis because they're about to have this really amazing scene together.
然后我写道，他们告诉休斯敦我们可以重新开始钻探了。他们为什么不告诉地球上的每个人还有希望？他们没有告诉地球上的任何人。我不知道。他们没有让任何人知道。他们没有让任何人知道。我确实有一个非常棒的剪辑片段，是本·阿弗莱克谈论与布鲁斯·威利斯合作，因为他们即将有一场非常精彩的对手戏。
Let's hear it. Bruce was actually a really, really nice guy. He liked hanging out with everybody. He made all the actors feel comfortable. he could have been really intimidating and difficult, but instead it was, you know, sweet. He was, he's a regular, sort of regular guy, guys guy, and just, I had a lot of fun.
我们来听听。布鲁斯实际上是一个非常、非常好的人。他喜欢和每个人一起闲逛。他让所有演员都感到舒服，他本可以非常吓人和难以相处，但相反，你知道的，他很温柔。他是个正常人，某种程度上是个真正的男子汉，我玩得很开心。
He was really, really nice, you know. Well, that's nice. I know. Well, they do reunite. They've taped up Steve Bouchem, by the way. They've taped him to a chair. Yeah, they can't risk him around, you know, weapons. They start drilling again.
他真的、真的很不错，你知道的。好吧，这很好。我知道。好吧，他们确实团聚了。顺便说一句，他们把史蒂夫·布西密绑了起来。他们把他绑在椅子上。是的，他们不能冒任何风险让他靠近武器。他们重新开始钻孔。
They're going to have to go another 250 feet in one hour, and they've hit a rough spot. Yeah. This is just like the training exercise. It is. And all of a sudden, AJ's like, you've got to trust me, Harry.
他们不得不在一个小时内再钻250英尺，而且他们遇到了硬骨头。是的。这就像训练演习一样。确实如此。突然间，AJ说：“你必须相信我，哈里。”
I know it can take it. Bruce Willis is screaming, back off, back off. And Ben Affleck is like, I can push through it. You got to trust me. And Bruce Willis is like,
我知道它能挺过去。布鲁斯·威利斯大喊：“退后，退后。”本·阿弗莱克则说：“我能挺过去。你得相信我。”布鲁斯·威利斯说：
this is our last drill bit. If this one breaks, it's not good. You know what? Bruce Willis is like, fine, I trust your gut. Yeah.
这是我们最后一个钻头。如果这个断了，情况就不妙了。你知道吗？布鲁斯·威利斯说：“好吧，我相信你的直觉。”是的。
So they pushed through it. And he was right. His gut was right, lady. His gut was right. He's oiled up. He's got a great set of teeth. And his gut is right.
所以他们坚持了下来。他是对的，他的直觉是对的，女士。他的直觉是对的。他全身抹了油。他有一口好牙。而且他的直觉是对的。
And his gut is right. Yeah. This is when I said, I feel like they really did need real drillers up there. I don't think astronauts could have done this. Well. They did it. They drilled the hole. They did it.
而且他的直觉是对的。是的。这时候我说，我觉得他们上面确实需要真正的钻探工。我不认为宇航员能做到这一点。好吧。他们做到了。他们钻好了洞。他们做到了。
They have to put the nuclear bomb in. But what they find out is remember when the asteroid started coming apart and there was all that mayhem? They find out that the bomb remote detonated. is broken. The trigger is dead. They can't get on the space shuttle and fly away and detonate it. Someone has to stay behind and do it by hand. Yeah. So, yeah. Yeah. They're going to have to draw straws. Well, first, Bruce Willis says he'll do it. Yeah. And then they're like, no way, no way. His men won't let him be the one. Also, why? Why? Why can't he be the one? I don't know. I don't
他们必须把核弹放进去。但他们发现的是，还记得当小行星开始解体并且一片混乱的时候吗？他们发现炸弹的远程引爆器坏了。引爆装置失效了。他们无法登上航天器飞走并引爆它。必须有人留下来亲手引爆。所以，是的。是的。他们得抽签。首先，布鲁斯·威利斯说他来。是的。然后他们说：“不行，绝对不行。”他的手下不会让他做那个人。还有，为什么？为什么？为什么不能是他？我不知道。我没
volunteered. But now everybody's volunteering, except for AJ. A.J. A. does not volunteer. No. And Steve Bouchimri really wants it. He's like, guys, I got it. this. I know. Well, you can't let crazy guy do it. No. So I agree with that. Yeah. So they agree to draw straws and AJ gets the short straw. Yeah. So Bruce Willis says, I'll take AJ down. I'll get him set up. And when they get down there, he sabotages AJ's space suit. Yeah, he like steps out of the airlock and then shuts him in or something. I didn't understand this. He does something to a spacesuit that compromises it. Mm-hmm.
自告奋勇。但现在所有人都自告奋勇了，除了AJ。AJ没有自告奋勇。不。而且史蒂夫·布西密真的很想要这个。他说：“伙计们，我来。这个。我知道。”好吧，你不能让疯子去干这事。不。所以我也这么认为。是的。于是他们同意抽签，结果AJ抽到了短的那根。是的。所以布鲁斯·威利斯说：“我带AJ下去。我帮他弄好。”当他们下去的时候，他破坏了AJ的宇航服。是的，他走出气闸舱，然后把AJ关在里面还是怎么的。我没搞懂这个。他对宇航服做了手脚，使其受损。嗯哼。
And then as AJ's like gasping for air, he shoves him back into the little elevator thing that goes to the ship. And it's airlocked. Yeah. And Bruce is on the other side of it outside on the asteroid. And Bruce is saying, take care of my little girl. Yeah. I cried again. I cried here as well.
然后，当AJ喘不上气时，他把他推回了通往飞船的小电梯里。那是气压密封的。是的。而布鲁斯在小行星外面的另一侧。布鲁斯说：“照顾好我的小女孩。”是的。我又哭了。我在这里也哭了。
Yeah. I cried. Yeah. Second time. Okay. I have an audio clip of Ben Affleck talking about shooting this scene. because he was really sick. Oh, yes, yes.
是的。我哭了。是的。第二次。好吧。我有一段音频片段，是本·阿弗莱克谈论拍摄这场戏的。因为他当时病得很重。哦，对，对。
Let's hear it. When we shot that scene, I had food poisoning. And I wasn't an experienced enough actor at that point to know that you can just pick up the phone and be like, I'm too sick to work today. I was like, I better come in. And I went in there. I was literally, it's the only times I've got me in my life vomiting between takes. They had a garbage can. And I probably made the scene better.
我们听听。我们拍那场戏时，我食物中毒了。当时我还不够成熟，不知道你可以直接打个电话说：“我今天病得太重了，不能工作。”我觉得我最好还是去吧。然后我就去了。坦白说，那是我一生中唯一一次在拍摄间隙呕吐。他们准备了一个垃圾桶。我可能让那场戏拍得更好了。
I mean, his performance is really good in that. I cried. I didn't cry, but I was like, I felt gutted. I cried. And then, well, here's the part that made me sad. I got a little teary because now I don't really know how he did it, but Bruce Willis's character here he's able to. He's able to call Houston.
我的意思是，他在那场戏里的表演真的很好。我哭了。我没哭，但我当时想，我感到心如刀割。我哭了。然后，好吧，让我难过的是这个。我有点想哭，因为现在我真的不知道他是怎么做到的，但布鲁斯·威利斯的角色在这里他能够。他能够打电话给休斯敦。
Somehow he gets enough communication. In his suit. Somehow to call and tell him. his daughter, he's not coming home. But he's in his space suit, but on the screen, he's not in a suit. Is that right? I didn't notice that. But it's very sad.
不知怎么的，他有了足够的通信信号。在他的宇航服里。不知怎么的，打电话告诉他女儿，他回不去了。但他穿着宇航服，但在银幕上，他没穿宇航服。是这样吗？我没注意到那个。但这非常悲伤。
It's very sad. And you know what I thought? He says to her, you know, you get married, you're going to spend your life with AJ. I thought, my God, these two can never get divorced. I know. I thought that too. I thought that too. I'm like, you better stick it out.
这非常悲伤。你知道我在想什么吗？他对她说：“你知道的，你结婚了，你将和AJ共度一生。”我想，天哪，这两个人永远不能离婚。我知道。我也这么想。我也这么想。我想说：“你最好坚持下去。”
You can never break up with this guy. Your dad gave his life so you could marry him. Yes. Well, guess what? It's not the end of the problems. Now, step seven is take off from the asteroid. Yeah. And the engines won't start. No. The female pilot and the Russian go down to try to fix the problem. She's trying to do some official things. The Russian fixes it by banging something with a wrench and they have lift off. Yeah. But the meteor is exploding randomly again. But you guys, they make it. They do get off the thing, but Harry is now out of range of the detonator because of all the things that are exploding randomly. And the meteor is about to cross the threshold of the barrier where they can detonate it.
你永远不能和这家伙分手。你爸爸牺牲了自己的生命，好让你能嫁给他。是的。好吧，你猜怎么着？麻烦还没结束。现在，第七步是从小行星上起飞。是的。女飞行员和俄罗斯人下去试图解决问题。她正试图做一些官方的事情。俄罗斯人通过用扳手敲打某样东西解决了问题，他们起飞了。是的。但流星再次随机爆炸。不过伙计们，他们成功了。他们确实离开了那个地方，但由于到处都在随机爆炸，哈里现在已经超出了引爆器的范围。流星即将穿过他们可以引爆的屏障阈值。
Because here's the thing. If they detonate it too late, then it's going to split in half, but the two halves are still going to hit the earth. Yeah, there was this line they had to like detonate before they crossed this line. But he presses it. He had only 20 seconds left, but he presses it. The meteor splits in half. Somehow, the blast radius from this nuclear bomb does not reach the shuttle, which is still very close to it. There's no way. When you see the special effect, it's sent like a ginormous sonic wave through space. It just would have obliterated anything.
因为情况是这样的：如果他们引爆得太晚，那么它会一分为二，但两半仍然会撞击地球。是的，有一条台词说他们必须在这条线穿过之前引爆。但他按下了按钮。他只剩20秒了，但他按下了。流星一分为二。不知怎的，这枚核弹的爆炸半径没有波及到离它仍然很近的航天器。这不可能。当你看到特效时，它在太空中释放了巨大的声波。它本该把任何东西都彻底摧毁的。
The space shuttle. Yeah. But they make it. It's okay. We have cheers at Houston and a row. around the world, a lot of slow motion celebration. Yeah. Again, dressed like they live on a prairie in the 1800s. Grace knows her dad is gone and Billy Bob Thornton hugs her. Yeah. The line that Harry said to her that got me before they lost radio contact, he says,
航天器。是的。但他们成功了。没关系。休斯敦和全世界的人们都在欢呼，有很多慢动作的庆祝。是的。同样，他们的打扮就像生活在19世纪草原上的人一样。格蕾丝知道她的父亲不在了，比利·鲍勃·松顿拥抱了她。是的。在他们失去无线电联系之前，哈里对她说的那句话触动了我，他说：
I'll look in on you from time to time. And that got me. That got me. You guys, once they land, you know, they get off the space shuttle. There's lots of hugging and like you said, right? It's in slow motion. Grace and AJ's slow-motion run to each other. Chick's son is there to greet him with a slow-motion run.
“我会时不时地照看你的。”那句话触动了我。那句话触动了我。伙计们，一旦他们着陆，你知道的，他们走下航天器。有许多拥抱，就像你说的，对吧？都是慢动作。格蕾丝和AJ在慢动作中向彼此奔跑。小奇克的儿子也在那里迎接他，也是慢动作奔跑。
Yeah. And I cried at that. Yeah. I cried at the fact that this dad was going to be back in his son's life. Yeah. Got me. Yeah. And AJ gives Billy Bob's character the shuttle patch.
是的。我在那一段哭了。是的。我为这位父亲能够重新回到他儿子的生活中而哭泣。是的。触动到我了。是的。而且AJ把穿梭机徽章送给了比利·鲍勃的角色。
Yes. And, oh, I also cried when Colonel Sharp wanted to shake Grace's hand because her dad was the hero. He said I wanted to shake the hand. of the daughter of the man who saved the world. It's very moving. You know, I have a clip from the DVD commentary where Bruce Willis talked about what it was like to work on this movie.
是的。还有，哦，当夏普上校想和格蕾丝握手时我也哭了，因为她爸爸是英雄。他说我想握一下拯救世界之人的女儿的手。这非常感人。你知道的，我有一段来自DVD评论音轨的剪辑，布鲁斯·威利斯在里面谈到了参与这部电影拍摄的感受。
Let's hear it. It was a nice change for me working with an ensemble cast like we had in Armageddon, all really funny guys. My strongest memory of now is how much we laughed every day and just try to keep cracking each other up. So it sounds like they had a really good time. This movie,
我们听听看。对我来说，能和我们在《世界末日》中拥有的这种全明星阵容合作是一个很好的转变，大家都是非常有趣的人。我现在最深刻的记忆是，我们每天都笑得那么开心，只是试图不断逗彼此笑。所以听起来他们过得真的很开心。这部电影，
It has a tag over the credits. It does. AJ and Grace get married. I loved that. It was lovely. It made me happy. And then the movie's over. And that's it.
它在职员表滚动时有一个彩蛋。确实有。AJ和Grace结婚了。我很喜欢那个。太美好了。这让我很高兴。然后电影就结束了。就这样。
That's it. You did it. Two hours and 31 minutes. You have one note. Yeah. I just think that during that final slow motion montage of everyone on earth being happy that the meteor was destroyed, it would have been really nice if we could have just seen bike guy hugging his dog.
就这样。你做到了。两小时三十一分钟。你有一个意见。是的。我只是觉得在最后那个慢镜头蒙太奇中，当地球上的每个人都为陨石被毁灭而高兴时，如果我们能看到骑单车的家伙抱着他的狗，那就太好了。
Yeah. And maybe telescope guy and his wife, Doddy hugging or something. Yeah. Just some resolution on those characters that we set up in the cold open of this movie. Oh, yeah. I agree. I would love to have seen the dog with like a Godzilla toy in his mouth shaking it. Something.
是的。也许还有望远镜男和他的妻子，多迪拥抱什么的。是的。只是对我们在电影开场白中塑造的那些角色给出一个结局。哦，是的。我同意。我很想看到那只狗嘴里叼着一个哥斯拉玩具在摇晃。什么的。
And maybe Doddy flipping off her husband, but like with a smile. Yeah. Like, F you, we did it. Yeah. If I had been in the room. Yeah. I would have given that note. Yeah.
也许还有多迪向她丈夫竖中指，但带着微笑。是的。就像，去你的，我们成功了。是的。如果当时我在房间里。是的。我就会提出那个意见。是的。
I would. No. Otherwise, otherwise. Don't change anything. Don't change a thing. Definitely keeping the leaving on a jet plate sequence. Sam, final thoughts? I love it. It's not good. I love it. That's a great quote. It's not good, but I love it. That's how I feel. Yeah. I'm excited to know that they had a good time, you know? And I really look forward to the road trip you and I take where we listen. to the DVD commentary. Can I add something real quick? Yeah. Yes.
我会的。不。除此之外，除此之外。什么都不要改。什么都不要改。绝对要保留乘喷气背包离开的序列。山姆，最后有什么想法吗？我喜欢它。它不好。我喜欢它。这是一个很好的引言。它不好，但我喜欢它。这就是我的感受。是的。我很兴奋地知道他们过得很开心，你知道吗？我非常期待你和我一起进行的公路旅行，我们在路上听DVD评论音轨。我能迅速补充一点吗？是的。可以。
I really admire all of your work breaking down this movie, your attention to detail. I found it so exhausting in the way you really got in there, took the whole thing seriously, looked into everything. I'm in awe. Well done. Oh, thanks, Matt. Thank you, Matt. We love a movie breakdown, guys.
我真的很佩服你剖析这部电影的所有工作，你对细节的关注。我发现这太累人了，你真正深入其中，把整件事当回事，研究了一切。我感到敬畏。干得好。哦，谢谢，马特。谢谢你，马特。大家，我们都很喜欢电影拆解。
If there's another one you think we got to tackle, let us know. Write to us over at OfficeLadies.com in our general mail folder. And we'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
如果你觉得还有哪一部是我们必须应对的，请告诉我们。在OfficeLadies.com的常规邮件文件夹里写信给我们。我们下周见。到时候见。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle），我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）。奥德赛的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《鲁珀特树》（Ruppertree）。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。